to
hello everybody it's Friday a beautiful
Friday in fact out here gorgeous weather
out here gorgeous
uh Happy uh September 22nd everybody
which is yeah
911 times two are they 11. oh my God
Four Towers that day gorgeous on 9 22
man never forget no you didn't even
think about that I will never this is
twice as worse as 9 11.
uh happy Friday everybody thanks for
being here God bless
thank you dude
Gamers uh for sponsoring today's episode
we love we love our sponsors we love
we're obsessed Sigma brain have you you
tried the same brand yeah sorry I
haven't had the decaf one all right you
hit that good good for you I love you
special today we are joined by a few
special guests our mods are in town who
we love
we love them
you
um this is let's start with Avery
he's got
he he's got the birdie cam you you did
you allow the birdie to um
find a friend new friend for the day the
birdie chose him today I didn't I didn't
allow nothing I'm honored to chose me
how special I can hear them I can hear
him wow it's so beautiful you know that
yesterday there was some crazy
phenomenon here I don't know if you guys
heard it there were birds like all day
yes flying everywhere of course Zach
knows
I I didn't notice Zach is the one who's
scared of birds though so I'm not
surprised they were flocking dude it was
I don't know what was happening
yesterday I wish somebody who studied
nature I called them over dude sometimes
at home in our chimney
yeah I've seen that actually it's crazy
and then the sound like amplifies in
your what like chimney the chimney
there's nothing funny about how I said
chimney chimney chimney that's my
chimney Cricket my chimney yeah
chimney cricket
it's got a m and an n
chimney Cricket
um we've got Ray with us uh who we love
thank you for being here Ray nice to see
you we've got Kevin who we love
um
sporting Hellman's merch in honor of
Zach
no that shirt's crazy yeah good
it's a Hellman's
race car
that shirt goes so hard where did you
find that yeah dude I love the design of
that where'd you find that
[Music]
where did you get that Kevin uh just on
Dale Earnhardt Junior's like Workshop
Dale Jr he ran this paint Scheme last
weekend oh he actually had a Mayo car
yep
that makes it better and then uh his car
nearly set him on fire wow dude there's
big Manny's money in NASCAR I didn't
realize
mayonnaise has got a huge reach into our
uh
to our psyche it's pretty incredible how
many times a week do you think about
mayonnaise no that should be a question
you like mayonnaise more or less than
the Roman Empire
more it's probably less for me oh my God
you don't like mayonnaise that's a
superior human being
that's essentially what he's getting at
through everything he says basically if
you read between the lines
and I see it all over in the comments
and there Dan can do no wrong
even one over Rich Lux who previously
hated him couldn't stand him we're
turning we're turning the haters around
over here on the History Podcast
remember that's the initiative don't
turn him to socialism yeah
was it the beginning of this year that
you declared you weren't going to be a
hater ass anymore yeah what
happened to that what what do you mean
why have you been less of a hater ass
this year when have I been a hater
ass this year hmm name one time
one
fairly consistently I would say really
name one I wasn't gonna say
well to be fair I think it was after
like one week I was like no this isn't
working
you gave it a good shot I feel like but
it does not work it didn't pan out
sometimes things just yeah things just
don't I'm just a messy
that is so real girl it's so real
um
you know uh thank you Kevin for honoring
Zach today is his birthday
hey
Mayo for Zack we said mail for Sam no
mayo for Zach today we asked Zach we
said what do you want for lunch today he
said barbecue he says what else do you
want
because I'm not eating damn ribs on it's
good live show good boy very good
did you say barbecue because you didn't
want the carbs no well Sam was talking
about barbecue and I'm like oh that that
could be good but
I'm very happy with what we picked oh
he's throwing Sam under the bus here
wait Sam because that's not Zach Sam
quick vetoed barbecue actually
yeah when I talked to Sam She quick Vito
oh we were talking about barbecue yo
hold on I did not she didn't do it no no
she was like that oh what the
I feel betrayed okay what happened
hold on Zach what recall the
conversation what happened we're like
should we order from this barbecue place
you said that
Sam Sam really they ordered from this
barbecue place is that right there was
leading But ultimately Zach
okay that is compelling so Sam suggested
let's order from the barbecue place
Zach you said that sounds good I'm like
that sounds good it wasn't even your
idea
what he did There's presented a little
bit a little differently to us
but regardless I think we ended up on a
we picked the grace yeah we're happy we
did well we're very happy with the
original well that remains to be seen
you know
so we got a great show here today
obviously I've been waiting to talk
about this Russell Brand thing
for a long time
um
the whole shell the whole atmosphere of
this story is fascinating because of his
very opportune uh shift into right-wing
Grifton that took place
so conveniently timed very conveniently
and even before this story came out
you've got all the morons of daily wire
and all The Usual Suspects being like
I'm not even gonna read the article this
dude who's like a known womanizer I'm
gonna read the article I'm not gonna
read it that's right yeah he's a Scott I
mean he's been a known womanizer and
like uh I think he said he's a sex
addict once and that he like cheated on
Katy Perry or something I don't know I
think it's all pretty well known I don't
know about the specifics maybe what I
said is all not true
but I don't think it is
I don't think it's known if uh he
cheated on Katy Perry but it's uh
implied this dude who's had sex with a
thousand women I'm not even gonna read
the article
but actually the article was pretty
damning and actually there's new
evidence that just came out this morning
which is pretty interesting which we'll
get into but
um
we're gonna go over it I'm not gonna
read it I am
okay I am Jesus that's Jordan Peterson
when he heard about it right how we read
it
he died he respected it he respected
women right right oh man this story is
great we found a dentist that is more
up than Jimmy we did we did like
we actually did no he is one up
Dennis yeah he makes Jimmy Lee look like
uh Dr Fisher okay that was the name of
my dentist when I was a kid
it's a nice guy good guy with the
tomatoes you're killing me
um this is a tick tock guy who's insane
uh mind-blowing uh you I mean it's it's
disturbing but it's also fun
because it's crazy
we've got Lauren gropert which is fun
lots of sexual crimes happening today
it's like I don't know if I've described
that as fun
but it is just a lot of that happening
today isn't it and every day
well we have other ones that aren't
about sexual crimes for sexual kick uh
for example oh no that one is too
no I'm kidding Pastor Jesse Duplantis I
want to talk about him
one of these uh gospel uh Prosperity
Gospel guys we gotta ride up on him he's
fun good time
I want to say thank you so much to
people saying that
um
that I'm looking good
because you are looking good it actually
means a lot right now thank you you look
really good
thank you I like your hair and your
makeup you've been doing a good job
trying to uh just kind of like
go more natural lately so this I just
let my hair air dry and I'm not doing
any heat your natural hair color
no well at the top it is yeah no it's
like at the bottom black the bottom it
is black I wasn't supposed to be black I
just wanted to match my roots but it
turned out more black but because I know
your hair is super dark but anything was
that no okay don't have more black than
I wanted but I'm okay with it so it
turns out I do know your hair color oh
yeah all these years you do looking good
and if I don't say so myself and I I've
been doing my own makeup so okay I think
you've been doing really good job thank
you I agree thank you it's kind of I
don't know if some people might find it
weird or funny but the ELA is kind of
new to the makeup
you're a newcomer yeah I'm liking what
I'm seeing thank you yes
um we're gonna play a game with the mods
too it's gonna be fun and uh anyway
here's speaking of which we have a game
here at the top
um that comes courtesy of the subreddit
that's right everybody
today we are playing courtesy of Misha
the Lebowski wait they did another one
did they all right I did the last one
that we did didn't we do one last week
okay they did the last game yeah let's
play guess that fun in collaboration
with c-man we have put together the
dream but okay that's right
um men only version ladies we understand
that if you got want that foot you gotta
pay
[Applause]
let's go up to our first contestant
thank you thank you up first foot number
one is that Ethan Klein or keemstar
Ethan Klein or keemstar guess that foot
Ela
I mean I'm I'm not wearing socks today
I'm hiding my feet though I feel like
that's not your foot I want to smell
feet anyone else ELO would know this
feed I'm gonna go with her Eli says not
my feet but I don't know I'm kind of
confused don't leave me astray here no
you should know I should know
what do you think
what do you think Ethan lock it in it's
a little similar but it's also not
final answer is say no no and Eva is
right oh yes
when I was prepping uh the dog I was
stressing I just looked at the first one
yeah let's see how the game went and I
wasn't sure thank you yeah I wasn't sure
I would have felt so bad if I got it
wrong I hate to say it but it does look
kind of safe it looks a little bit like
it but also not oh no his yeah I know
there's minor hilarities yeah yours are
nicer for sure similar height similar
hand size
you're not like an elevated version of
this thank you
up next we have oh man
take a look at these things
see Manny your heart out is it Andrew
Tate or hassanabe guess that foot I'm
not familiar with either ones but I'm
gonna guess Andrew Tate I have not seen
his songs yeah I don't know if I've ever
seen it I think he guards those he got
closely I feel like they wouldn't be so
narrow yeah
yeah right he's got big shoulders
interesting fit right he's probably got
clown feet
[Music]
Andrew Tate yeah
[Applause]
right which of course
am I right folks thank you you have said
it I had a weird Aura Andrew Tate has a
three you know there's a war happening
on Wiki feet still and
we gotta get that a little bit lower
we've moved past those Wars you know I'm
banned oh man this is a tough why is
that foot number three nickato or David
dobrik
I feel like this what is that I feel
like it's not tough that's got to be
Nick right yeah that's like a soft and
also just the position like I feel like
Nick's off Nick often times like rolls
back with his feet in the air which like
that angle seems to would you ever see
dobrik in that angle that's what I'm
saying he's only behind the camera I
feel like it might be David and David
when I first saw it
yeah you're small could be yeah yeah I'm
sure could be a purple as a film big boy
I'm a backup Dan that's a lazy boy angle
you know get comfortable getting relaxed
all the way thank you thank you Avery
yes that foot is naked let's take a look
here we go and that foot number three is
oh yeah no surprises here my friend I
would have been so embarrassed
number he's only two stars
okay tough crowd out there huh
seriously
up next we have oh is that foot liver
king or Bradley Martin
two swole Kings
eats only meat if it was liver cancer
mostly eat meat I say there would be
more veins if it was liver King I think
it the reason I think it's lyricings
because it looks kind of little
like if you drawed the body on that
you drew the body on that
does he wear no shoes liver doesn't wear
dude
he wears the air he wears a musk maybe
it is it's a coat that's true when it's
barely when is Bradley walk around
Barefoot I think it's liver
it doesn't seem veiny enough to be
little that's yeah but Bradley's Jack
too he's got veins would also be swole
yeah maybe maybe whose foot is that I'm
unsure I'm unsure on this one here it is
that is Brandon Martin and let me save
Bradley a respectable score
good score wow yeah those are hot feet
real I'm sorry who accused Bradley of
not being vascular wow yeah
oh my God liver King yeah
is compared to that
what is that I wonder what liver score
is compared to that oh liver is going to
be down in the thing I mean
let's look because I'm liver King not
that Ricky feet he is you can smell his
feet man
3.72 stars out of five pull it up on
fire than I would have guessed I want to
see some pics I want to smell feet no
man it's up I'm not on this page
anymore it's really not fair you
around oh here he is in his wife um
resting in their Shallow Grave
ready to be burned at the pyre
[Applause]
we have to get rid of their bodies
before they Fester
if it seeps into the groundwater we're
gonna have a problem you see the firearm
on the uh
on the whatever the that is next to
his head the what there's a Gun there's
like a giant gun there is oh this yeah
you just oh murder suicide bro I don't
believe for a second you sleep like that
dude you sleep in a bed with beautiful
cushions wait is that what this is
supposed to be yes no this is
exactly
give me a break bro and he doesn't take
steroids oh and this is like their
nightstands he admittedly he admitted
but now he's apparently off it but he's
back on it for sure yeah this is so
funny he's back into lying about it
though or maybe he's up front I don't
know I don't think he ever stop
personally there was like a couple weeks
where he was getting noticeably smaller
I think he just Photoshop himself
smaller for like a couple weeks
he was fully doing his stack then well
regardless he's definitely not off it
now
we can say that for sure
it's however after 220 days clean he
admitted taking steroids again okay at
least he's honest he's back on it but we
didn't really get to see his fit up
close well here I mean the best I can do
oh yeah
let's take a look at Brian's feet
I mean yeah those look pretty good
they're more normal those are nice you
know those are those are nice
I don't know they're okay it's okay
pretty good foot it's pretty hot 188.
yellow that yo he weighs more than me
wow wow check your beat check your body
mass index King who's obese now
[Music]
42. don't ride I know the I know the
body mass thing isn't really stop
um
here he oh you do the helicopter
Barefoot very cool
dude your life is a joke man
you're like parked in a canyon
via helicopter and holding up some kind
of protein barefoot
and
some people's fantasy I guess but the
helicopter is not giving Primal it's
just not
you know you gotta like fantasy I want I
need he needs to travel by Caravan or
something right just you know pick a
lane man
okay well shout out to King he's got a
pretty good shout out
up next whose foot is that whose foot
is that
what is that Howie Mandel's or Jared
Leto's foot
this is uh that's hard no but how we
paint his toenails he's silly he might
that's the thing I feel like this is
very deceptive I feel like we're
supposed to immediately jump to the
Jared conclusion because of the toenails
yeah but that could be a red herring
I'll tell you this Jared Leto definitely
has his toenails painted he like I'm
sure of it sure right but this for some
reason is giving me more Howie than
Jared I don't even know why well it's a
youthful looking foot
if I can say that but how he does look
phenomenal for 67 I mean he's the he is
the yeah for sure he does yeah I mean
what's he's got the Fountain of Youth
almost what about the what about the
flippy floppies do you think how those
are giving me Howie that's good in your
house Jared Leto's probably wouldn't
wear flip-flops because he's too like
high fats yeah right except when he's
doing his cult thing he's probably
wearing some Jesus that's true I feel
like he would like wear moccasins or
something when he's yeah
something more like over the top I think
so too I think flip-flops are too pleb
for him
you think how I know me and Howie are
tight he said he'd do anything for me
when he was talking to Jimmy you think
he'd give me like a pint of blood
[Applause]
a gallon I don't know how much can I
take I don't know well how much blood is
in a person how much blood what no how
much can I take without him dying that's
what I wanted okay what's this you know
what let's ask Chachi PT yeah that is
going to give you an accuracy that's
what it's actually good to Ask Judge UPS
though for that one I don't know why you
guys seriously think Chad should be too
such a joke like I genuinely this thing
is so good you guys are sleeping like I
genuinely had a very in-depth
conversation with chat gbt about
socialism
and it referred me every Source you
referred me to was a real Source that's
good it's a single one it's like
Wikipedia you gotta just uh treat it
with some skepticism I think I said give
me your sources follow up and confirm it
follow up on uh what it has to say the
way you describe having a deep
conversation with it funny
for titles for highlights
you do yeah put in the title I make and
do you have any examples for this
I don't I never take anything He
suggests but I take parts of this
because you like the way you like the
way it phrases something yeah give me 10
other um yeah exactly and you I I pick
in shoes all the all his suggestions
very good very good so the most uh the
most common type of blood donation
typically takes about 500 milliliters
which is about a pint so if I text him
now can you ask what kind of benefits
can we subtract from somebody by using
their blood I don't know but I'm just
gonna drink it and pray
I honestly I don't think that he would
need like a very specific reason I think
as long as he clarified with you that
like you needed it he would be like I'm
gonna I'm gonna text right now Howie can
I get a pint of blood
wait maybe you should ask his blood type
first
I don't say by the way what is your
blood type
[Laughter]
well does that matter if I'm just
drinking it I'm not transfusing it oh
you're just trying to drink though oh I
guess I should transfuse it Oh I thought
you wanted to like do you think yeah
become more youthful like
I want it too I said Howie can I get a
pint of blood by the way what is your
blood type I'm just texting him that
yeah I see how he let's see how he
handles out
I don't know my blood type do you
no I don't I do know mine I think I'm a
b one percent of the population are you
oh are you an oh no no no no a b
negative I'm a positive oh positive give
me that blood yeah dude my vein baby if
any of you guys are dying as long as
you're positive I can save you right and
you're someone can save me though and
you're a big guy I could probably get
even way more than a pint
you've got a little bit of fat strings
but we can I can get a barrel of blood
so oh
are you do you say a B positive or not
I'm negative maybe negative no you're
positive if you're positive is the uh
maybe that's the top here apparently
this is a b negative one percent it'd be
positive four percent oh I meant as far
as uh because you are a universal
recipient recipient oh that's the good
one because you can get blood from
everyone
because I mean obviously that I'm
whichever one is the negative so I may
be negative no you're positive girly I
just know that I'm the one that's one
person you're always really positive
don't put yourself down
and it actually came back positive you
know
whatever the science says it's dead or
wrong
I refute that all right whose foot is
this I'm gonna say it's Howies yes whose
foot is it it is
beautifully scored four out of five and
I and I'm telling if I was on Wiki feet
right now I would give him a five star
rating
and a beautiful shark
really beautiful shirt to be honest what
was that meant to be Zach
was that sound meant to symbolize
the squirting sound what was that yeah
go on okay wait what the dude you
are not just colliding a wall
oh God he is so ill he is so unwell
oh is that have music it does I muted it
he's morbid my dude
what is happening dude you are like the
attention starved 15 year old oh he's
he's gonna realize he can't keep going
and then just come down what is he
climbing me
it's a side of a hotel I think
oh to say hello to his adoring fans to
sneak into someone who's bailing sneak
into some woman's window
he's bailing he's just trying to pull
Focus like always
is running away from an investigation
are you coming down I sent this to show
what kind of slides yeah
you're right he has some weird
avant-garde slides yeah damn that was
sick dude what he just did yeah
that was sick Bro dude that was totally
cool I wasn't trying to cause a scene
he's just so low-key he doesn't want
anybody to notice him what is the what
is whoopsie
Whoopsie whoopsy Daisy I need a machine
gun whoopsy-doopsy tagged it and it's
like
whose foot is that
whose foot is that is that Logan Paul or
Jake Paul let's Breeze
who can guess I'm gonna Breeze Logan
Paul three out of five
[Applause]
is that Ryan Cavanagh or Harvey weiner I
said Ryan well what's the difference
there's none yeah I mean it's clearly
different we have a whole website it's
called Uh right
he does Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
Weinstein doc hold on let me type Ryan
Kavanaugh yeah don't go to the website
Brian Kavanaugh trying to search for it
scroll down it's easier to search it
here it is number oh there it is under
wickets
like Brian Kavanaugh right well it does
Harvey Weinstein look like rank or no
does rank have not look like Harvey
weinstein.com if you spend some time on
this website then you will be able to
tell that this is in fact
Ryan Kavanaugh thank you
this is Ryan Kavanaugh no you got it
wrong I do
no that's Ryan
oh it says the name in the top oh it's
here oh I see okay so wait this is Ryan
no this is Ryan yeah this website
um I thought was supposed to make it
clear yeah oh there's labels on it it
actually says yeah and that's that's how
you sell it okay
see you know oh God okay this is Ryan
this is Ryan oh okay wait what did you
say under that image do you see it under
the image of him bro
it said um this image is altered so that
you can tell Ryan apart from Harvey
that's nice guys go to that website if
you want to learn more whose foot is
that I don't know man but I'm gonna say
Ryan because I don't think Harvey's got
many foot shots he's been in prison for
a minute
one one benefit of being out of prison
you're on wikiFeet there it is it's Ryan
no that's Harvey wait that's hard that's
hard away dude
it does say Harvey it's Harvey
I read the website this morning sorry
I'm pretty sure that's horrible way back
on the label it says it right there it's
Harvey Weinstein he doesn't have red
hair though Harvey I thought he had like
all right this is very cool maybe when
he was younger because I think it's just
kind of grayed and thin but maybe when
he's this is a young photo
oh man not that young I mean he still
looked really old there
washed up and possibly drunk okay well I
guess go to the website if you want to
learn more
[Applause]
um all I know is one's in prison and one
soon to be in prison just kidding
[Music]
that's just a joke I don't know what
he's he's probably not going to further
okay love sent me just to bring me clear
this is Ryan Kavanaugh oh
he looks real healthy yeah youthful he
looks like a foot I you know
what
you know what Ryan you can keep your
blood thank you we don't want any of you
to run to have anything over here are
you sure look how youthful one is like
no the hairstyle I don't want it okay
okay this is not a real photo right this
is altered keeping it why would it be
what the is going on with the
butter it's just bizarre no that's I
think that's a reason
it's just so bizarre yeah that's a real
imagine looking at this in the mirror
every morning
though
you know who he's been mean to a lot of
people though that's true he's a mean
guy he's in me right back yeah
all right Ryan take care we we we're
rooting for you in the words of jail
right always
and that's it thanks for playing
everybody see you man love what a fun
game Guess that foot and thank you once
again to Misha the labsky who prepared
last time Jimmy Lee or dictator yeah
that was great which was a huge hit
it's a lot harder than this game
um judging oh do we have a new Ryan post
so maybe this is this is irrelevant to
our conversation I was about to say I
forget exactly what the details were
didn't Ryan have a anti-bullying like
organization or something that he was
launching does he you know what I'm
talking about and it is also like ahead
of fire department here he invented the
fire department
he invented the fire department
he invented putting out fires invented
firefighting in California
he posted this inspirational by unknown
he says he said the fire will not bully
us yes
we will not back down to this fire
judging a person doesn't Define who they
are it defines who you are nobody knows
wait hold on that's written really odd
judging a person doesn't Define
they are it defines who you are the way
it's right there
it should say judging a person doesn't
Define who you are who you are and they
find who they are they're judging you
it's a little confusing nothing is on
fire I have a feeling that unknown
person was Ryan Kavanaugh
and myself why do you feel the need to
spread negative things you haven't
confirmed on your own confirmed on your
own what do you even mention that part
perhaps looking inside will fix
something you didn't know was bro I have
a feeling he's writing this directly to
me what kind of like this motivational
thing is this why are you assuming that
I am spreading negative stuff you know
it should be like it should be to make
me feel better about negative stuff
about me dude I'm all about peace love
unity and having fun these are the
principles of KRS one
[Laughter]
this is a reason please love unity and
respect bro well I guess one of the yeah
maybe that's it's just a slight
variation he says and have and fun
that's from a song again these are the
things of KRS one there's a reason the
Torah only puts one sin on par with
murder and that's gossip you do not
believe that hopefully
[Music]
Ryan you do not believe that because
that is scary what
what there's a reason that Torah only
puts one sin on par with murder and
that's gossip he's doing
that is terrifying product I don't
comments turned off
wow could we fact check that you're the
Jew I don't know about the Torah
what do I know well I know about the Ten
Commandments which like there's ten of
them is there one about gossip uh there
is actually I don't speak ill of your
neighbor
Jews gossip's a liberal I feel like it
took a little bit of Liberty here let's
see I mean but they see they see gossips
as bad as murder
let's see graven images no other Gods uh
uh lord's name in vain
Sabbath
uh honor your father mother don't kill
don't kill us all the way down in seven
well they're not if it was that big a
sin I think it would be number one I
don't know or number ten either way the
numbers matter though I don't know it's
not like higher program
uh thou shall not steal bear fault
witness adultery and covet covet covet's
kind of no that's jealousy that's
nothing to do right okay well then it
sounds like what are you talking about
Ryan it sounds like we're all clear it
sounds like there's no sin here and by
the way while we're on the The Ten
Commandments let's just remember that it
doesn't say rape on there so
that should be there I feel like that's
a huge oversight on God's part just
saying or maybe Moses scribbled it out
real fast I mean adult adultery not just
cheating adultery is cheating it's not
art it's not right yeah I guess adultery
means cheating huh yeah no and Fidelity
yes yeah there's cheating there I mean I
think I remember adultery yeah I mean
it's defined as voluntary sexual
intercourse between a married person
yeah
well then it sounds like that's a huge
oversight in my opinion yeah I think God
should have talked about that God
totally left more Commandments yeah we
need at least one more at least one more
and frankly we could lose a few of those
we need to add gossip obviously which
ones would we lose can we pull up the
ten command let's let's do it obviously
the one about like no image or sculpture
that one's so dumb yeah it's like
as a kid I was like what
tough because he's he's an insecure I
mean excuse my French but he's just
really insecure he's kind of alone okay
excuse my language but even the Torah
the commitment thing is that technically
like a sculpture and an image that
people but it's his it's his
because like he went down and then they
had the golden calf and he's like hell
no everyone's getting killed for that
I guess
I see what you mean though it's just
it's really dumb I see what you mean
it's very open for interpretation to put
that next to like like if you're gone
I'm gonna write these rules that are so
clear yeah so Godly that this you know
exactly what it means but I don't
actually
you shall have no God before me I mean
I would get rid of this one only because
it makes you look insecure right and all
just from an object that's it yeah and
like I get that you won a monopoly uh
you know where's your self-confidence
you know like that's what it's all good
baby if you're a good guy and why would
we want anybody above you know right
like just hey you know what if you
didn't want me then good luck with those
good luck in the afterlife
uh so I I got a hot tip got a hot God
tip from the chat here uh it's called Uh
lashon Hara hopefully saying this right
talk badly about it I didn't see that
there you go yeah it's not in the
Commandments but it is a very serious
sin in the Jewish tradition according to
this as that is
are you killing people
because I know sure as you gossiped
before we all have murderer
you probably gossip about me all the
time
ass
you shall not make any Idols to worship
this one is just a little again
confusing as you pointed out
what is an idol it's so confusing
because like
it's like you can't have a picture or a
sculpture it's like what the
it's again a little insecure yeah you
know
if you're if you're confident in your
godness
you know play it cool baby right you
know I got the power it's all good yeah
there's a lot more competition back then
yeah dude God has mad red flags for real
if God was on a dating app none of y'all
would pick him
only like the really up girls who
are like I want a guy who's like a
little crazy a little controlled
controlling and crazy
you shall not take the lord's name in
vain
I mean again I'll give him this one just
because I feel like kind of repetitive
too it is like chill you're kind of
breaking this there's only 10. you know
you could have combined these whole
three yeah like just just be respectful
to me right you know I am your father
let's just have a little respect for
your father right which I which is one
too honor your father and mother is one
too that's your actual father-in-law
yeah he's like I'm your Godly father
but then maybe they could do that you
think he could be more sophisticated and
like not waste Four Points you make a
good point out of 10. all four of those
into just respect the father me and your
dad yeah All fathers the the biological
father and the
spiritual and shout out to moms too and
the mother
shout out
so you shall not take the lord's name in
vain I mean I guess if I had to pick one
I guess like I said I won't take too
much away from him he's just like don't
talk but I'm like okay if you're on
my team don't talk about me that's
fair right
because like if you're homey if you're
chilling with the homies and one of
them's talk you finally he's talking
behind your back that's gonna cause
a rift
he's like man what did you really say
about me
you're like did you really say that I
burned all your crops that made your son
die of dysentery
come on bro
that wasn't me that was Vishnu come on
man you did that
sorry if that's offensive I don't know I
guess I'm being super offensive to
Christians though so most of the Vishnu
people like Jews and Muslims Muslims and
now you've thrown in the Hindus
I'm having a panic attack over
here wait what the Big Ten are pretty
big in in Islam of course they are of
course yeah also this is a thousand
years before Jesus this is wait does it
make you uncomfortable it's it's my my
middle eastern upbringing I'm going to
we're going to Hell by proxy right
now look at you you're a mess you're
messy let's end on the good note I was
like let's not talk and I'll give
you that one well we left out the last
like major world religion in Buddhism do
you want to insult the Buddha in some
way can we like I don't think Buddha
killed anyone he's just chilling in like
Enlightenment ask chat GPT he kind of
mining isn't he just like I just want to
be by myself I just want to be alone man
just leave me alone
I'm just playing though feel free sorry
baby oh no I'm just messing it's fine at
least we'll go to hell together yeah
okay um chat gbt has confirmed that the
Buddha did not kill anyone they didn't
do any anything wrong here's Ryan
kavkave as Moses don't be mean to me
bang my wife better than me that's a
commandment that's just crazy
wait it's missing one comments off
comments off
well that's almost don't be mean to me
and number three please give me more
money for the filler right
I command the investors I'm sorry Abby
no no you're good I'm just messing
around I'm just saying that I respect I
respect your uh
respect you know stuff every day I do in
my life I hear my my religious ants in
my head that's I'm not being serious
it's fine
I actually didn't know that uh we shared
the Ten Commandments oh yeah I thought
it was just a Jewish thing I didn't know
that they cared about it that much yeah
yeah no like the first one is it's like
the uh there's only one God and that's
Allah that's like the first words in our
book so okay yeah are they all the same
yeah
[Music]
and they with Moses oh yeah and you
gotta you gotta think of okay think of
think of it this way you have Judaism
that's like the original release right
and then you have an experience and you
have a DLC yeah called Christianity this
guy Jesus showed up and he was a Jew and
he like added more content yeah and then
a couple hundred years later Muhammad
shows up that's like a second DLC okay
and so it's all building on Spanish you
still have the original in there it's
like the Lord of the Rings you know
that's the best way anybody ever
explained that to me it could be like is
it like Godfather because in a sense
like the Christians are like we didn't
like part three
and the Jews are like part one is better
that's like um it's like when like a
expansion pack comes out and the
quartering's upset because it's too woke
like yeah this part's gone too woke or
whatever I'm not playing that yeah
part three was not good yeah they
screwed up the ending it has its moments
and it has this moment and they should
have never casted Francis Coppola's
daughter as his daughter as Michael's
daughter
right
he was talking about part three maybe so
careful right that's your part
um here's something which filmmaker oh
somebody said don't even get started on
the Mormon pack oh brother I got plenty
to see about the Mormons
don't even you're right don't get me
which filmmaker accused of horrible
crimes also owes Ethan Klein six one
thousand
[Music]
this is frozen
or two this picture on the left right oh
man that's crazy well I don't know which
one is one or two I guess I'll just say
the guy number one or number two because
I don't know
horrible crimes
he was accused of horrible crimes but
like they were also retracted right in
the case of the Ponzi anyway I don't
know it wasn't the crime I'm not aware
of other horrible crimes or I guess
maybe there are but I don't know
specifically what
but it was retracted the Ponzi one yeah
I think it was number I think the number
two though is the answer
if you consider that the horrible crime
was retracted and not
not just accused but also retracted yeah
yeah it's not necessarily there's so
many other things he's been accused of
right yeah like specifically what's one
like how he was accused of um offering
to donate a million dollars to Habitat
for Humanity but that's not a crime
though well that's not a legal crime
well okay let's let's say let's say it's
a crime in the um in the loose sense of
like uh an injustice yeah not
necessarily illegal moral crime it's a
moral crime well yeah okay there's a
promise to give somebody a million
dollars no not come through no not
especially Habitat for Humanity yeah why
don't you just go piss on the Boys and
Girls Club of America oh you're at it
I'm pretty sure the Ten Commandments
would not allow that somehow one of
those points one of the it would
probably fall under one of them at least
one of them is you shouldn't treat
um I don't know how you I heard that one
is written in English but you like
perhaps um respecting your your mother
and father uh it's just like you're
you're um there's the other one about
like you shouldn't treat somebody how
you want to treat yourself yeah I think
that's the Golden Rule but what about
Thou shalt nice well actually I'm not
gonna say that I'm not trying to get
students
I think we could say he was accused of
um horrible moral crimes yeah there you
go because that I that's true I mean
yeah right we get an updated meme with
an asterisk with a long legal can you do
that please Kim I just want to be good I
just want to be clear let's go that this
is our opinion Avery's on it don't worry
yeah
[Applause]
he's a good guy though we're rooting for
you Ryan yeah mm-hmm always definitely
rooting now and forever we're all
rooting for you buddy
um um
we are uh 46 minutes into the show how
long 46 46. we have too much fun on this
show wow sucks the time just flies by we
have so much fun man seriously I've
already been at almost an hour
well that also means that it's time to
thank our wonderful sponsor who we love
love love who is our sponsor today gamer
sub
it's time to sup up
I love talking about human stuff because
this is our flavor Sigma brain
is there reviews on the website yeah
dude this is Gamers I I promise you I'm
not blowing smoke the best flavor yo
there are there are
and the word on the street is good it's
good I would really like to hear
what people think about it I guess
there's no there's no written
there are mail for Sam bruh brudges
broad juice
the while to come around to the flavor
but I'm absolutely loving it now
definitely tastes the best cold yeah
yeah I mean yeah you gotta drink up you
gotta drink flavor not into spicy foods
and I love this there you go it's so
subtle the spice which is a little
tickle on your taste buds yeah I just
gave it to Avery for the first time what
do you think Avery um
I think it's life-changing man I'm very
much
wow that's good wow your parents is one
of the commandments so I'll tell you
Avery you said um and I got nervous
here I remember reading this four star
one just to be fair this guy gave it
four star he says good but great cold I
could tell you that you got to drink a
cold you have to drink a cold yeah he
says drink it really cold
um it's great though well this is good
because this is this is honest you can
tell yeah and it's it's informative I
would definitely enjoy lime flavor with
a dick if you think a very mild spicy
lime flavor you may just enjoy this up I
love lime flavored things and enjoy
spicy Mark so this flavor is a win for
me
I don't want to uh they're just it has
they're just giving a heads up that they
have caffeine when they take it they're
jumping off the walls which that's a
plus for a lot of people so well they
have the non-caffeine burgers and
there's an old caffeine version fair
warning as with any caffeinated gamer
stuff this stuff provides ample energy
for gaming workouts bouncing off the
walls and never sleeping again
sleep when you're dead sure why not
finishing a serving five hours ago and
still kicking with energy dude that's
Batman oh my God yeah I don't feel
from caffeine ever
I have never felt caffeine in my life
and I don't know why I do but I don't
get that it doesn't I literally don't
feel anything ever
no I definitely do but I would never
fill that oh
maybe they just had a fat beverage of it
I don't know a couple scoops
I don't really believe you
don't feel any and I I have seen you get
wired up on caffeine on this show no you
haven't yes I have no you haven't Dan
you think you did it's the thing is is
it's subtle so you probably just don't
realize this now basketball dude I can
have two coffees and go to sleep I've
been diagnosed with ADHD and something
that does exist is sometimes caffeine
doesn't affect people with ADHD okay I
don't have that I know but that's why
for me I've never been diagnosed anyway
I know people say I have that but I
don't think I actually do hmm because
yeah literally I can drink coffee and
then I can go to bed but also I can
drink Gamers up all the time I crave it
right and I can drink it right before
bed sorry guys I can drink caffeine
before bed it literally doesn't affect
me I'ma back up my girly Olivia cause
caffeine makes me sleepy yup he makes a
go to sleep so gamer stops I get the
non-caffeinated birds and I I get the
flavors and I get the juice or maybe you
have it before bed yeah yeah either a
little a little night cap
dude I I'm more with Avery it makes me
sleepy if anything Elite you back me up
no sometimes we both drink coffee at
night but I do but it doesn't I'm not
gonna yeah but I do drink it in the
morning to wake up I do I'm like a
zombie before I don't even notice I
don't even notice if I don't have a
coffee I like physically look sick until
I have coffee so I
yeah that is true
I literally only drink coffee because I
want to fit in
yeah no I think that when I look at
those long it does it for me yeah when I
look at like Starbucks I'm like these
people are just trying to fit in I'm not
waiting an hour for coffee
I never even started drinking coffee
until I was like out of college
with you I didn't feel left out I hate
coffee yeah coffee's it doesn't tastes
good no it's you have to convince
yourself that it's good and I have
my mom used to make us coffee since we
were kids so I think I'm it's it wasn't
my choice but when you were a kid you
were sipping coffee she would make us in
the morning like a pot of milk with
coffee in it like our own flavors you
call it milk but it was coffee she was
po she was drugging you she's like here
have some of this milk get you ready for
the day
God bless man whatever works you know
it is what it is I just get chocolate
milk so it looks like I have coffee but
I know because I get what Ethan's saying
but at the same time it's like I don't
want to fall asleep in the middle of the
day especially if I'm doing something
important dude chocolate milk is fire I
do not know that I'm pregnant and I
wanna yeah yeah in a social setting and
I can't have coffee I get a chocolate
milk but here's the thing I love me some
gamer Subs I I only drink chocolate I
know if I put game or something
the good thing about gay stuff is like
first of all it's packed with vitamins
electrolyte it's super hydrating it
tastes great it's gonna keep you
energized if you like caffeine you don't
want caffeine they have non-caffeinated
and I'm telling you all got to try this
flavor
don't sleep on it and you won't sleep on
it because there's caffeine in there
gamer Subs go to gamersups.gg use the
code H3 to get 10 off your order
try it guys you're gonna love love love
it
we had a five-star rating can I ask
though is there any flavors that don't
have a five-star rating I'll take a look
all different flavors because the the
reviewers are extremely quite generous
on that one on that side you say that
I can stunt on those lower rated ones at
least
there's quite a few people who their mom
also made them coffee Hispanic oh really
somebody said their mom did the same
thing
seeds of pneumonia No Seeds of Nema
pneuma
seeds of pneuma new members gifted 20.
thank you so much
Grandpa's ashes
who's new it just doesn't happen who
made this flavor what
is this this isn't a who made this
flavor Grandpa's ashes this is epic
what does that taste like
pretty wild is that a real flavor I have
to ask because they have weird it
is it is wow it's pretty collaboration
with Goons with who goons PC I don't
know I love that they do this kind of
stuff though it's pretty funny pretty
funny what flavor is that Grandpa's
ashes
anyway try the same with brain that
gamersupps.gg use code HD retention off
we love them thank you
hey come on let's go
[Music]
feel it out
by the way Dan confessed
on the record live that one of his
forebears is a radical communist uh
red uh revolutionary
and now that it's out of the bag we
found him
one of his what this is Dan one of Dan's
uh uh four Bears one of his uh ladies
and gentlemen one of his uh ancestors
see any resemblance that's Grandpa
actually I don't really there you go
yaakov Yakov sved
chairman of the Secretariat of the
Russian Communist Party
bro are you sure you want this going out
are you a Russian
I have no connection to him he's like uh
it's not my the post said great
grandpappy it's not it's like great
great uncle or something I mean it
wasn't that long ago he died in oh no
that was even when he died when did he
die because he he served 19. oh that's
he died really young I was looking at it
the other day he died when he was 33 and
that was tripping me out because this
dude like overthrew a monarchy and like
did all kinds of crazy and
I'm three years older than he was when
he died how old was Alexander Hamilton
when he died because that dude like
built the whole let's see Alexander
treasury he fought in the Civil War
built the whole treasury I don't I did
not fight in the Civil War Sir I mean
the Revolutionary Works
uh he died in 1804 he would have been
fairly old at that point he's 47 okay I
mean even that's still youngish that's
crazy
47 is not bad I mean it's not great
but it's not bad he was in it for the
long run so here he's got quite a
write-up though so shout out to uh he
was very much in the mix with all that
you think he killed anyone killed a lot
of people really yeah well I mean
Russian Revolution was extremely bloody
so yes sort of love was born to Jewish
parents that checks out
um his father was politically active
engraver
who produced forged documents and stored
arms for the Revolutionary Underground
this word love family had six children
two daughters four Sons
after his wife's death in 1900 Mikhail
converted with his family oh there it is
to the Russian Orthodox Church good I
don't think you want to be Jewish run
then
it's not ever really a good time
married Maria uh had two more Sons his
father was sympathetic to the children's
socialist tendencies
and five out of six children will become
it's cut off but probably communist or
something
very good let me get you get the idea
yeah love that for you
oh so exciting we're basically closed
our deal for the live show yeah
I'm I'm not a hundred percent but I'm
like 90 that we're gonna put them on
sale on Friday next week for members
I mean there are other members at first
we should say
that's exactly what I did say oh I
missed it verbatim
so sorry I think this new venue has like
3 300 seats
uh it's uh I'll tell you exactly how
many so you're more so if you're not a
member there's a better chance that
three oh you'll have access to uh the
tickets but
I'm happy to announce the venue it's the
Dolby Theater gorgeous place man
very excited about that there are uh
about 3 300 dicks
this is gonna be like such a um
such a
epic venue I mean it's so amazing that
we're able to wow so for people don't
know if the Dolby is a big theater here
in Hollywood and it is where they film
the Oscars oh wow yeah so we are going
to be on this evening can we do the
steamies there
well I didn't want to necessarily throw
that out there but oh is that an idea I
mean just an idea I mean it's all right
well we had discussed it previously we
had discussed uh dude that would be fun
to do the steamies live how exciting
will you be live at the same time
we should get somebody to do the red
carpet interview with like
people we could accept their Awards oh
my God this sounds amazing yeah let's do
red carpet interview and then let's
invite people like Gabe and um and Jimmy
and Howie and carrot he can come if you
want
you guys are best friends just everybody
gets to talk to the Press
live oh my God this is this sounds
spectacular yeah I might have to I'm
going to dress up for this imagine the
Wild Card nominees that'll show up we
gotta we gotta get some nominees out
that'd be sick you know
this is an important uh award show the
hottest night of YouTube and I'll say
this it's YouTube's biggest knife it's
YouTube's sexiest night
and I'll tell you this
the Streamys could never sell this they
don't condone the balls to do they don't
even sell tickets oh maybe Jay Shetty
could do the red carpet interviews yo I
wonder if he would because we're dogs
now oh my God there's beautiful eyes
involved that's to be so funny we took
their golden he might he might do it yes
my God this is going to be a great time
so it's all happening in the Dolby
feeder it's a new theater it's got great
Tech apparently good sound it means
Dolby
it's not that new now I know it feels
like it's new because I thought it was
like 2001. that's newish
[Music]
you know
I was 16 at time that's pretty long ago
um but 22 years yeah I'm super excited
oh yeah we can do a red carpet there no
that that'd probably be really expensive
huh that is Hollywood Boulevard
Hollywood Boulevard for this well we can
get a permit I can afford that yeah
but I do wonder if we could do a red
carpet moment it doesn't have to be I
think we could do it back and have them
walk it yeah live and then people can
watch or we can do it on stage so the
audience can watch
oh man that's gonna be so much fun wow
this is gonna be the biggest streamings
ever and we got a bone to pick I mean
steamies and we got a bone to pick this
year
I will potentially be making
I'm not gonna say that
I'm gonna button myself before I even
say it
you know now we have two different
layers of protection not to speak the
button in my brain and the buttons
wow this is exciting so looking forward
to
this man's really pulled over on the
freeway
um
I do see cars okay
he's in the driver's seat I'm slightly
concerned wait
Gabe are you okay buddy
looks like an ambulance
bro are you really pulled over on the
hot freeway right now you have your
emergencies on
is he called in so clearly he had some
level of Consciousness before he called
Gabe are you okay
should we call for help okay he's all
right
all right all right
go ahead Dan all right so anyway
this was a cool study that came from the
um subreddit
[Music]
um
I thought this was pretty Illuminating
and and uh context of course of our
leftovers from Thursday yeah yesterday
obviously contentious issues lots of um
strong opinions
and this guy crunched some numbers
apparently he's a data scientist or what
did he say he's a data analyst
he says hi
um he says Ethan keeps reading members
chat for some reason I want to say this
I did not read the members shot once
yesterday I had I didn't even open the
stream one time and we all appreciated
you for it
I read one comment that was like dude I
wish either would stop reading the chat
because he keeps obviously reading
there and regurgitating it and sounds
like an idiot well I'm happy to tell you
that everything you heard out of my
mouth yesterday was all from my own
idiot brain
original takes
if it looks like I am I'm typing
something
um he says yada yada I got curious I've
been a member for like two years and
I've chatted like four times I think
most people are the same me so during
the peak 15 minutes of Friday's end show
the debate part
uh which was contentious at least in
some people's minds sure not ours 200
Chatters made up 60 of the total chats
whoa that is that is an interesting data
point he's so he's he took total
messages seven thousand y'all doing 23.
wow
top 200 comprised 4
252 200.
wow this was total chats by default
YouTube put your chat in the top chats
was totally obscure to me how YouTube
picks these chats they seem not to be
consistent at all so I recorded this
data in all chat mode his methodology
was uh he couldn't get he tried messing
with the YouTube API
so he did his own janky way which I
think made sense to me screenshots the
chat
um parses the names
wrote a script
and then he used a computer version of
OCR
uh and then he said that he took
snapshots every
four SEC four seconds bro how are you so
smart yeah this guy's insanely what's up
how do you do that
this guy's sick he's so smart see all
the smart people like him all the cool
ass dudes they only they don't chat
hell no never mm-hmm
so um I don't think I've ever typed
anything in a well I guess because I
type in our live chat but I mean I don't
either when I'm watching The Stream I
never chat almost never I mean you guys
see me when I comment it's very rare do
you love because you're in the twitch
culture
um no I kind of if I watch someone that
knows me like um like a friend yeah I'll
I'll show you never know then but never
when it's like a big streamer it's
pointless
so he said the same people's name could
be counted twice though I did scroll
through and most of the top 200 people
have unique names so it's not that big
of an issue he thinks so that I thought
was really actually super insightful
thanks for doing this yeah cool the 200
of the same people from Price 60 of the
chats I would have never guessed that
number never I wouldn't guess it was
that high but it does make sense because
most people are just watching the show
you you would have guessed what I don't
wouldn't think it would be that high but
it makes sense that low you mean no 60
yeah yeah gotcha like because most
people are just chilling or watching the
show a lot of people are doing something
else when they listen to a podcast I'm
just chilling and Cedar Rapids and it
takes a special kind of person to be
arguing in live chat
and you know you are a member so we do
love and value you but you are a special
person
I think rather than making about that
very special perhaps you should just
it's just make it like oh I shouldn't
get too worried if I'm seeing negative
feedback because it's such a small
sample size yeah I'm hearing right we
can look we could go that route too
right it is very interesting though
really thank you um too yeah Nori shoe
really good data that's kind of
mind-blowing to me yeah oh very good
thank you sir appreciate my Chatters
don't feel offended me what I didn't say
I just
and they would agree I'm not I don't
mean special in a bad way it's just
clearly they're not like other people
because most people aren't chatting and
arguing in the live chat they're special
they're special they're built different
yeah that means special doesn't it yeah
they're different we love you build
different means you're not like other
people what a special mean
absolutely do the math you're special
you're beautiful you're privilege we
love you we love you very much
[Laughter]
let me love you guys
uh where are we
uh that said um send me that list of 200
names I'll just ban them all
I was going to tell you kidding
that's a joke that's a joke there
it's a socialist Purge
[Laughter]
um
people noticed this and yes it was
[Music]
foreign
as I was saying
that's so good oh I love that so much
you guys the button
saves lives it is
prime plus
pause
now the button is circle and it's not a
rectangle
because it's like right what do we think
about it um
maybe a rectangular is bad because I
don't know how to really do but it's way
more complex than that because the unit
itself is a rectangular and then it has
two circles in it which is
yeah right I don't have a hole in me
that's funny dude our mods got to see a
behind the scenes of the button oh all
right I didn't even notice the cam
pointed it out man it's like traveling
two times it's time travel baby
oh the Wormhole it's really fine as a
viewer and I love the screens they're
always so creative and then you get to
like speculate what happened how bad was
it dude the screens that people have
made are so tremendous I'm gonna update
it on Tuesday this upcoming week so if
you have more make it over the weekend
if you want and feel free to uh they're
amazing they're amazing you guys are
doing amazing just came to me one needs
to be a Back to the Future one because
of the sound bite and two should be some
kind of Wormhole traveling we're
traveling back in time 30 seconds bear
with us in the DeLorean yeah you want me
to make this for you I can do it oh it's
just a general uh
you know just a general call out Avery's
made some of my favorites on there he
made oh yeah go for Dave's green one
yeah yeah nah I've done some other work
to work too on the human Vlog channel on
the hill climb channel so yes I got you
guys done all of them
okay Dan is this real because this is
not cool I mean you said he murdered
people
like I know he's your grandpappy but oh
you're asking if it was cool for me to
take a selfie with him yeah the thing is
is that this is a this is a fake image
and it's oh I'm frozen oh oh you've been
silenced this is a fake image right here
I've been censored I've been censored so
you're saying this is this
yeah
okay I'm back I don't know what happened
there socialist said what anyways
anyways uh that's a Photoshop that's not
a real
um only killing he was doing was cranky
90s by a guy in fortnite
no let's go yeah it's your birthday
[Laughter]
anyway cranking 90s so I was more just
kind of baffled by that expression you
were cranky I know what you're talking
about that you're cranked the
90s I play with you
okay Dan you're playing fortnite now you
got to learn this
you're playing fortnite we played for a
few minutes is Dan good he is good again
Dan's a gamer I still play fortnite dude
it's massively popular it was like me
Ian Dan and like a bunch of kids and
I'll tell you this I don't play fortnite
but I respect that game so much because
they they are updating it with fun
that looks super fun all the time and
like I got mad respect that they can
keep that game fresh yeah uh they I
don't know how long ago they added it
but when we played it there's um
an item where you get like a rocket Fist
and then you you shoot it and it drags
you along with it so you're just flying
all over the map good every time I
see gameplay it's some weird crazy new
yep and Diablo 4 could never they
could never hit I literally paid them
for their first season and it was such
dog shame on them I didn't know
that people still playing yeah dude it's
probably still one of the most played
games right It's gotta be yeah and I
gotta say fortnite's like the Smash
Brothers are Shooters because they get
like crazy collabs like you got like
Travis Scott like shooting Thanos and
cranking with Kratos in the updates
and then they also like put in the game
like events from the movies right yeah
there's like there's like Velociraptors
from Jurassic Park right now and Optimus
Prime that's sick okay they also have
these sick MLK uh huge collab with them
okay tributes
I'd collab with the estate of Martin
Luther King Jr yeah that's not a joke he
got cheated though you should have
gotten the skin you're gonna know that
[Music]
uh I don't know Schindler should get a
spot in the game he's you know
did a lot for us Ian was playing with
the uh Mr B skin and I was the ninja
yeah he was Mr Beast oh yeah Mr Beast by
the way it's still one of the top games
of view watched on Twitch Diablo 4 for
example has like 20 people watching it
nobody cares it's such a disaster
failure of a girl and I want to stomp it
out of existence W for shame on you
blizzard World of Warcraft I thought you
played like 300 hours of it except your
friend he's the best yeah I appreciate
him a lot
no I I mean I I definitely put in like
some time for sure
but
I'm over it now I've moved on
um so anyway back to this yes so Hassan
class Trader Hassan he brought out
a can of Prime energy by capitalist
coward scammer Logan Paul and put it
right next to my beautiful drink of the
people
um socialist uh utopian drink gamer sups
okay you can literally get a sample for
free that's for the people right
that's for the people right uh but
there's a fight you can't do that huh
it is a funny story though I got a text
from
Prime energy
like a couple weeks ago
oh oh how we respond he said I don't
know my blood type but I continue two
points of urine immediately
okay I can work with that like
see how he's a good sport
speaking of urine
I've been holding it for a little while
um I got a message on Instagram from
Prime
and it said
they said hey Ethan it's a lit
meet globeberry
is every everything's cool yeah yeah
we're just we're just talking not
about you you talking about me
during the show lose weight till after
no I know you're kidding uh so Prime
Mastery said Ethan it's a lit meet
glowberry eyeball Emoji Eyes Open Emoji
our new mysterious flavor
uh is here
we'd love to send you over an exclusive
case let us know the best address and I
was like this is so bizarre
I want them to send me it just so I can
like talk about how horrible it
is but I'm gonna give it a true taste
right now so Hassan tried it he said it
tasted like he did say that and it
does and I haven't tried it yet but I
think it was just but anyway here's the
video
who are like on their own Journey okay
and they get like really passionate yeah
and I'm proud that is so slick oh my God
people are saying I'm a real
professional and
I take credit
I love it the thing is people were
confused about the perspective like it
was on his side of the desk but
I'm reaching into his into his sphere of
uh existence there so here I'm gonna do
a live test of this Prime that they were
so kind to send me and I'll just see
I'll give you guys a review of the
flavor
wow
dude what do they put in that ship are
you serious that was fast is this a is
this a
no that's definitely what it's meant to
taste like yeah I mean that's that's
what came in the Box no this one's got
to be bad or something there's no way it
tastes that bad that's what it tastes
like
how do you know somebody I tried a sip
earlier I also spit out dude this is
dude they sell this
not in all countries I don't believe
it's not actually allowed in Canada
hold on is there an expiration date on
this
Sonic Sonic smells awful like that stray
that you just smelled it out I can smell
it it's like can you can you empty this
please like burning my mind smell it
this is fat this is vile yeah bring it
outside it's like it's like they bottled
Tsum strowman disgusting
I gotta I need to I need to wipe the
flavor out
um
all different oh there's another one
maybe
um
this is how you wipe that flavor out
right here
that's such a nice flavor the sigma
brain from gamer Subs that's a good
flavor to try
that's good that's clean
at whatever I don't care glow Berry shut
up
anyway
shut up thanks for sending the prime
guys yeah I appreciate it on their own
Journey okay and they get like really
good oh I played it again
thank you so much is that do I smell
food yeah it's here I've been smelling
that for five minutes now
oh we did something good definitely did
come out of the debate because we got an
okay Ethan sound bite from Hassan
sick listen
like go ahead
it's tangent because okay Ethan but like
go ahead
it's
more like a transitional right like a
exhaust exacerbated yeah
but pretty good it's I mean it's useful
for us yeah
it's good it's going to be useful go
ahead Zach let me hear it
okay Ethan we should do um okay Ethan
but like we should okay Ethan Fearless
okay even but like
he always does
I agree
play them all
what the happened okay Ethan but
like okay Ethan okay Ethan yeah see so
many of them like the rest like
they're like can we hear her songs
without the rest of it just it's not
clean enough I tried to make it like
yeah
there's only three four uh no I mean
there's the you could do the one of him
going okay
um
Ethan there's that one that one's good
what about the Tourette's guy he goes
doesn't have a moment no let's have a
good night
well Jeff obviously is like I can't feel
like I feel like Jeff is that's probably
s s here S Plus tier yeah okay Ethan
there's like a queen yeah no it's clean
it's clean man uh what else we got here
um people are asking for pregnancy
update sure good idea
um honestly I don't have much to update
just still going
still feeling tired all the time but
otherwise uh everything's fine
everything's good
hungry like crazy coming Scotty's
cooking I'm always eating like it's
crazy
yeah I keep having dreams about Shredder
but they're nice dreams really I'm happy
when I I'm happy and I'm enjoying them I
haven't had any
you haven't no do you remember I mean I
mean whatever
really my dreams yeah yeah
I want to think about it yeah
um
here's a this was kind of a breaking
story from Today cartoonishly evil
politician was caught bribing in America
a Democrat this is so wild this man they
found here he is dude what
dude why do people look like this
wait who are they who are you you're not
real this is AI face this is not real
people
they found gold bars in his house
like straight up he was being bribed
with gold bars what why do they look
like that
what
um so he was being he was uh over
acceptance of hundred thousand dollars
in return for the use of senators
influence to enrich three New Jersey
businesses and benefit the Egyptian
guard he's being bribed by the Egyptian
government
he's denying it but they found more than
480 thousand dollars in cash in his
house most of it's stuffed into
envelopes and hidden in clothing closets
and a safe
this guy had so much money he couldn't
even put it fit it on the safe
apparently it hid like money in shirts
that it said his name on it he dude 500
000 cash even a hundreds that's got to
be a whole lot that's so messy
including jackets bearing the Senator's
name that's awesome he's like I did this
he's like it's not my jacket says your
name on it
and more than 70 000 in a safe deposit
box the evidence they have presented
paints a pretty cartoonishly and
blatantly evil uh scheme
here's some text messages with the
businessman where he basically lies out
exactly what he's doing for money dude
you look like that God how does he look
like that do you know what I'm saying
you know I don't can I play that
he looks like he looks like the Israel
pardon me but I feel like I've seen
people look like that no you know in
Mario 64 when you can like pull his face
yeah yeah that's him
hmm
somebody pulled his face and it hurt too
man
like whoa dude
it's like a subtle pull where you're
like that doesn't look right
let's take a look at his text I feel
like I have people in my family that
look like that okay
no comment
I'm not that I've met your family is all
beautiful wonderful people no you
haven't met a lot of them I met him at
our wedding
you did like hi nice to meet you hi hi
200 people hi
Hi how are you thank you well done
I'm gonna so here's the um here's a
screen capture
I'm gonna do that 99 million
International arms deal you wanted of so
here it is
um
Nadine that's his name
he says tell Will
Nadine's the wife oh so she's yeah
so she's like his secretary in bribery
sure because she's not an elected
official is she
uh no so even like theoretically could
he like even if this wasn't illegal
could he involve his wife and like
um in like a state pinning on hers no
like even if it wasn't illegal can you
just like hey can you talk to um
governor for me and just tell him
like that's weird even just well do you
know what I'm saying why are you wearing
my wife I mean yeah probably not if
she's not an employee she's like hey can
you take this uh
these access codes run them over to the
White House for me so anyway Nadine is
talking to some Egyptian official tell
will I'm going to sign off on the sale
to Egypt today Egypt said 46
000 uh 120 mm target practice rounds and
10 000 rounds tank ammunition 99 million
no these tank grounds are for tanks they
have had for many years they are using
these in the Sinai for counterterrorism
campaigns was that added or or was that
in the conversation
it doesn't know it so I'm not sure it
looks like it's in the conversation it
looks like it's in the conversation
Nadine forwarded this text to Hannah who
forwarded to the Egyptian official
Egyptian official replied with the
thumbs up emoji
wow cool we're good to go on the bribe
here
I always blows my mind how little they
get because like I know half a million
dollars is a lot of money but he's
hooking them up with like a hundred
million dollar deal where does it say
what he gets that's what I was trying to
understand well I don't it's not
mentioned here he's just selling they're
selling them some munitions
for 99 million
which I guess is a hook up
I'm assuming Jesus
um he was paid in cash cars and also
gold bars is my favorite
check out this dudes
man this dude's selling drugs bro look
at this okay you know what's so good
about that Senator Mendes he has his
name on it he had envelopes of money
jackets with his name on it oh my God
it's so bad it is kind of fire huh yes
and imagine walking around with his
jacket on that guy has gold bars wait
can we do a senator Mendez uh capsule
just blinged out
um gold bars yo this man has pulled
apart what are these worth one kilo of
gold what's that run
he was wondering the same thing which is
another thing that he got in trouble for
as you're about to find out
I was wondering how do you even do this
do you go around
right come off well if you're him
because gold like is forever valuable so
some people like sure but how do you how
do you liquidize it I mean I'm sure
there are ways there's obviously a shady
way to take someone there's a bunch of
gold uh Place sell your gold jewelry
places.com they have two kilos of gold
bars
they're like okay that's not weird 62
000 for one
they have their stance by the Swiss bank
with a serial code how much 62 000 for
one for one dude that's that's money
yeah that's so fire a gold bar solid
gold it's a lot of gold
stamped by the Swiss bank with a serial
number
I don't know where this came from
yo we got that nice bands a convertible
life is good for Senator Mendes
Brothers
foreign
after getting the bars he Googled how
much is one kilo of gold worth
no before you got paid you didn't know
how much you're getting paid well he's
he's a car he's cartoonishly dumb he's a
shot yeah he's like cool Scooby-Doo
villain on or about October 17.
uh he returned from Egypt at described
in paragraph 29 F landing at JFK airport
upon their arrival a driver
um picked up uh Nadine
from the airport and drove them to their
home in New Jersey the next day they
performed a web search for how much is
one kilo of gold worth
as discussed wherein multiple gold bars
provided
were found during the court authorized
search of their home
so funny
that's awesome
I mean if you're getting bribed know how
much money you're getting
right
they're like two gold bars he's like
okay whatever
I'll figure out I'll find out that
sounds good to me
there it is what's this guy's story is
he like what kind of politician is he oh
he's a Democrat and he's been in his
positions uh he's been in Congress one
way or another since 1993 so he's long
holy long term he was a congressman
for a long time and then in 2006 he
became a senator so he's the senior
senator from the state and um he also
was uh already indicted on bribery
charges a few years ago and he kept
doing it and he got off because of a
mistrial the a deadlocked jury and then
they ended up just dropping the charges
doing it well he's like I mean why
not away with it once and he met his
wife at IHOP in 2018. oh let's go what a
guy she was working at IHOP but now
she's was she a waitress she it seems
that way
he married an IHOP waitress who he then
used as a co-conspirator and a primary
school
intelligence service he's like let me
ask you this
I'm a senator
if I went to eat Egypt to collect a
couple gold bars what would be your
opinion on that
hey man
I love it here this is what I'm talking
about do you not see it
I don't see that I guess okay
thank you Kim
but was he like a super liberal like I'm
curious like what was his whole platform
I don't know a lot about him I mean
he's 69 and let's see which in my
opinion you know let's get him out of
there
69. God damn man this dude's been
serving almost as long as I've been
alive
[Applause]
he met his wife at IHOP pancakes which
the center has praised as his favorite
dining spot
okay I like IHOP I'm not even gonna hate
IHOP slaps pretty hard oh yeah no
judgment there
dude IHOP's fire
the pair began dating a hashbrowns
oh yeah they got hash browns they got
everything there the pair we got dating
in 2018. oh there's so this is a new
Romance
this is a brand new Romance
or well not a few years five years I
expect at that age you know that's new
for his lifetime yes according to the
indictment which she was unemployed at
the time what she can be in prison now
from IHOP to prison thank you senator
there it is
shout out to uh Menendez I love it who's
gonna rot in prison hopefully or maybe
he'll just get off or not and he'll just
keep doing it i j i do let's track that
I want to know what his CR his
punishment is for
defrauding the American people
or the people of his State I don't know
I mean how many people live in New
Jersey
no it would have been American yeah I
mean because what he did was use his
influence in the Senate to get these
deals and so that's money being spent
from taxes they should get a year for
every person he defrauded so 350 million
years yeah
um there that is I thought that was kind
of a kind of a laugh yeah
I mean God forbid the guys who are
actually slick about their corruption
Jesus seriously of which I'm sure there
are many because in this case seems like
he wasn't even trying to hide anything
no like yeah just texting him not that
even knew how this was probably at AOL
um Stephen uh donated he said hey Ethan
I'm short on gold can I get an ounce
thanks all right I got message the mods
a little bar
um okay fun we got to the uh Russell
Brand part
I gotta go to the bathroom
all right and then we'll come back and
do that
too love said one kilogram of gold would
change my life or no who said that I do
say that too oh you said that I didn't
said that I saw it somewhere
I gotta go to the bathroom we'll be
right back okay all right okay
um a lot of birthday wishes for you Zach
coming in happy birthday Z money thank
you hey happy birthday happy birthday
Zach it's my birthday too oh shout out
sorry Fuego happy birthday
sorry Fuego
uh sorry what else we got here
uh we got a shout out for uh Avery too
we love you King
shout out
quick wire says so
thank you
uh Canadian here I know Prime is banned
but the gas station I visit literally
has a whole shelf yeah didn't we talk
about how there was like a prime
smuggling operation going on to uh
to Canada
from Canada
Prime
why is it so complicated to get it there
I think just because they they have
different
safety standards and like rules and
stuff you know than the United States
they probably will eventually but I
don't think it is yet
uh
uh what else we got here
somebody said uh donating 50 bucks and
said this is for ELO brings out the
inner Barbie in me since I started
since I started West
since I started West Teddy fresh
maybe where where Teddy fresh
baby
Teddy fresh exploring more in my
wardrobe and making me feel comfortable
to wear whatever the I want with
confidence
hi Liv Sam and Lena I'm happy to hear
that
hi
I was chewing sorry
uh I am from the UK and coming in LA in
November please what's the day of the
show it's going to be in December my
dude I'm sorry
it's gonna be um last year when we did
the first of these live shows that we've
been doing recently at the Vermont it
was our last show of the year before we
went on winter break that's how it will
be this year too so I don't want to say
the date because though we have an idea
it isn't fully confirmed yet but should
be soon but uh late
December let's just say that before
Christmas
for Christmas
um let's see
what else we got here
oh people are some people are saying
that it is everywhere in Canada Prime
saying what thing some people are saying
that Prime is everywhere in Canada that
they do see it everywhere okay well
maybe it's changed I just remember
um what was it it was some uh
I think it was actually Logan
oh
when he was like
clapping back about people being upset
about prime or something he's like it's
not even in Canada we don't even sell it
in Canada if you're getting it in Canada
it's it's bootleg oh
some bootleg ass Prime up there
Prime is totally legal in Canada there's
a huge display of it in every Circle
okay okay well maybe something's changed
that was a couple months ago yeah it was
a couple months ago that we talked about
that
uh Zach's birth okay
this dude just sent 100 bucks Zach's
birthday gift for me
don't send money to the crew as a super
chat I was very kind but it's very kind
but stop doing that yeah please stop
doing that it's way too difficult to get
out and YouTube takes a huge cut of it
they take 30 so you know
Zach's got a cameo
yeah why don't we say that sure Cameo
you want to donate to Zach go and pick
yourself up a cameo again thank you very
much but yeah don't do that yeah very
generous is that can I buy a cameo from
you for you sure best musical cameos in
town I've heard all right right he'll
like write you a song I will write you a
song he goes all out on these yeah I
want you to write a song about yourself
okay you got it dude my man my man
I want to hear that that's a good idea
maybe
um
what else we got here
Eli I ordered Teddy fresh in my local
post office returned it before the
expiration day and now I won't have any
of the Trixie TF collabs smiley face
that's why why does that make you happy
oh there's a little tear it's one of
those
that's where it is that like an
international
situation sounds like it they use the
term expiry date
[Music]
um another place I would suggest mailing
the support team they're always really
helpful
and I'm sorry that happened what
happened
their package was sent back before the
expiry date by the post office so they
never got they didn't pick it up in time
and probably because they didn't notify
them maybe that happens that's
up what happens
what happened
what happened should have happened what
should have happened happened
it is what it is it is what it is and
what should have happened happened right
oh yeah I just saw that bees of space
bees from space just donated five uh
Euros oh I love him since I've been
playing lies of P y'all tried it yet
also new rectangular remix is up on my
channel now oh he did a rectangular
you did a rectangular remix interesting
be there and be square nice oh the B's
in space man thank you guys who won our
green screen competition he has so many
hits I'm a huge fan bees from space
um
rectangular remix let's check it out
and to answer your question I am not
tried lies of P yet but I am curious
that's the one it's the bloodborne clone
oh but it's Pinocchio it's like
it's like edgy violent Pinocchio he said
he likes it just what we needed I've
been hearing really good feedback about
it and yeah they did uh actually they
didn't say if they liked it or not but
if they're asking I assume they did I'm
curious to try it Dan can I put or Dan
uh Zach can I put Ranch on this what's
your what's your take yeah dude
try the ranch first it tastes specific I
like it you like that right oh okay you
know what else Sam just busted out the
sugar-free ketchup you want to try it
I mean just curious not really also
thank you guys very much for the burger
it was really you're welcome very good
very good I always hit this sugar very
high thank you delicious
I love that ketchup I mean it tastes
pretty close no I like my sugar
yep you're not a fatty
I'm pregnant I mentioned to Zach that uh
I got a patty melt so my sandwich was
rectangular and everyone else
well done dude dude this is a circle it
sucks
so I'm with you wolf oh yo let's go
there you go let's go
oh before I play this while eating I
have permission from bees from space I
have permission okay nice before before
you pause it every like 15 seconds or so
and let it remind us yeah I can do that
[Applause]
[Music]
my friend Neil bent over this happened
thank you
[Music]
this is the first time for me
no homo
[Music]
all right
wow
holy
I'll say this
um this guy is really a talent yeah
he really is something I'm gonna do this
uh I'm just gonna finish this so you
guys don't have to listen uh watch me
but what I'll do
that I'm sure everybody will love all I
need is two minutes
is enjoy this
um award-winning
video presentation Fly Me to the Moon
you're gonna put this on him and slam
your burger yeah is that the plan yeah
good plan
[Music]
nice
[Applause]
ask you again
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
my God
[Music]
[Applause]
I love you foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
enough time for me to
engorge myself and I am done what'd you
think of the burger great good spot
really good it's a good spot that's a
big ass burger there was like different
tiers of how much meat you wanted
all different flavors I don't know if I
got the smallest or the medium but it
was like massive
good I can't imagine going like full
beef boy on that
you go full Beef Boy love I don't know I
will be I didn't like it that much you
know like a huge one you says I took a
took I think I took it a big one and I
didn't like it that much you didn't like
the burger no show me the cross-section
love got like the three oh dude that pad
dude that Patty's insane all right show
that to the camera he got like a three
pounder dude yeah that Burger's way too
big it doesn't make sense I think I
don't know it looks like they cooked it
through too mine was a little pink
there's something putting me off with
the flavor that just makes me not want
to eat it all that I don't know I I'm
usually not
criticism critic of food
I like the price
um
thank you for the free burgers by the
way I really appreciate it oh don't
worry about it thank you thank you thank
you no problem no problem
let's talk about Russell Brand
this coleslaw is not gonna happen
I can tell this is a bad idea I'm gonna
put this in the fridge or later
this is probably the worst one of the
worst foods actually so crunchy loud
takes a long time deep
I do love coleslaw though you know what
else I'm starting to love it's a little
odd raw onion
dude raw onion in the burger
is it is it um
is it coleslaw or coleslaw
poll coleslaw yeah okay that's what I
thought what did you say I I always I
never know how to pronounce it is it
coleslaw or coleslaw what are you saying
coleslaw cold like coal oh coal like
burning the whole coleslaw yeah cold Sly
I think that's something else
I think that's what they call it on like
the coal mining cave uh Falls in and on
all the miners like some black like the
black coleslaw this is coleslaw the yeah
coleslaw coleslaw coleslaw but it's
spelled coleslaw isn't it no it's
c-o-l-e
that's coal Coal is c-o-a oh right but
yeah
what
so
right am I crazy tell me what you're
saying it is cool like when you start a
fire coal like you know you used to
burn right is c-o-n but they're
pronounced the same yeah okay just
making sure we're all on the same page
about that right but it's right so it
sounds the same yeah cool that's why I
was confused I didn't know what the
Zach what are you wearing yeah now I'm
confused because that would mean you
said it the same
is it coleslaw or coleslaw I use the L
so it's coleslaw to me
coleslaw coleslaw it doesn't really
matter I'll tell you how it's spelled
c-o-l-e what the ugly girl you're
so right yes in Sweden coal is uh
cabbage
oh which has to have some kind of
connection right well there you go
absolutely yeah how do you say it in
Swedish it's pronounced coal maybe it's
a German thing yeah coleslaw coleslaw
yeah something like that
connection
no no no no no Jesus Christ Jesus yeah
it says uh comes from the Dutch term
yeah cool in Dutch sounds like dude I'll
tell you what the Germans they know what
the to do with cabbage they got all
kinds of cabbage tricks
they got sauerkraut they got coleslaw
that's all they have
those are big ones though chocolate
they're big and I mean they're all
different flavors I mean cabbage is not
an easily it's not easy to eat that is
like
thick gnarly roughage and they they turn
that into one of my favorite
um dishes
so mad respect to the Germans on that
guard
and I want to give you guys a big thank
you today for letting me eat lettuce
this is all I got out of it absolutely
just a nap signed off on that what was
that a piece of lettuce hey Avery we
told I told you don't give him food
I'm sorry take that lettuce back don't
fire me please I'll take it back
all right just listen to my instructions
next time no food for Cameron we have
one rule here yeah that man doesn't eat
here's how it's pronounced
coal Coal slaw Coles coal here here it
is coleslaw
why did it open a new window
oh
at the top I got it coleslaw coleslaw
coal coleslaw that's interesting because
that's how you pronounce it in Swedish
coleslaw coleslaw coal
codes
coleslaw could you have cold coleslaw it
should be cold okay I think
apparently it comes from a Dutch word
coleslaw k-o-o-l-s-l-a
coleslaw cook is a sloth coleslaw slaw
all right guys let's talk about Russia
thank you for clarifying yeah Molly you
know that was asking how you feel about
kimchi
I don't like it oh boy you up I'm
so sorry I thought I expected to love it
I really did and I wanted it's like you
like pickled stuff I love pickled stuff
and I and usually I like what people do
with cabbage but the flavors for me just
it just wasn't hitting for me
and I'm generally just not a big fan of
seaweeds and the sushi and the raw
seafood and all that kind of Cuisine
that goes with it it's just not my okay
it's not my cup of tea okay it's not my
Cuppa
I'm sorry to disappoint you well I'm
sorry to the people who are probably
going to be deeply disappointed by the
answer and maybe some are UNS
unmembering dude bulgogi is probably the
best thing I've had out of here Kobe
bulgogi and Coke bulgogi
oh you don't know what that is it's like
is it Korean barbecue I know what that
is yeah it's Korean cold bogey bulgogi
I've never heard that people say that
again
wait am I crazy isn't it
people call it Korean barbecue
okay well I know what Korean barbecue is
but I only heard I think it's a specific
yeah it's a Korean dish
yeah really it's just meat they just
cook is that where you cook it yourself
or no it's just a big ass stir fry it's
just meat I don't know dipped in some
beef we went to um it's really good
is that when they cook it in front of
you or is that the one where there's a
grill at your table
what's the one there's a grill at the
table so we went to Hibachi it was
really nice we want the boys it's fun
yeah it's a nice experience
yeah the boys the boys had fun too how
do you like cooking the meat King of the
stuff yeah I I love doing that
stuff the problem is you come home and
you just reek of it oh God
so true my hair was like so stinky
afterwards yeah
I love that I like the way you stink
[Laughter]
my favorite perfume is meat
it's smoked meat baby when I get home
from my Korean barbecue that's just nice
speaking my love language
flavor I need to bottle me some of that
Smoky Meats flavor perfume around these
meats on the meat shop
grilled fish scent know your way around
some meat
all right let's talk about Russell Brand
This freak you guys like the title by
the way
I love it what do we title it he's such
a loser man we all knew he was like a
creep right like everybody knew that
this brand is a weird freak loser and we
never liked him anyways can we all admit
can we say that we never liked him or
can we not admit that who invited him on
the podcast once so I don't think you
can say that that doesn't mean I didn't
like him it was just I think he would
have been an interesting guest
loser wait hold on didn't he reach out
to us no
no allegedly
he followed me
he followed me on Twitter I think maybe
you saw that he followed you and so you
tweeted at him invited you were like hey
like publicly tweeted and then he dm'd
that he dm'd you in response and said
sure but then they goes to us they did
Ghost us yeah he said yeah I'd love to
come on your show message my actually
that's not fair they didn't ghost us
they said that he's busy they did
respond so
probably would have erased that episode
anyway no I don't know if I would
probably not well back then he was
probably talking about some real uh
normal
I think so no I don't know no he used to
be like a lib didn't he
I mean it's just like kind of like
there's a certain
he's like it's complicated there's
there's certain he gives Homeopathy yes
that he was very much into that and
that's the thing there's like this weird
like hippie conspiracy theory Community
I don't think he used to be the
community that like it's hard to Define
as like left or right because they have
very
um
uh specific beliefs depending on like
what aspect you know they love nature
and probably and believe that climate
change is bad but then they don't
believe in vaccine science you know what
I mean like there's a lot of like
contradicting I know for everybody like
that or like if you don't eat organic
then you're gonna get cancer right yeah
a lot of skepticism of like big Pharma
and the agriculture industry and some of
it definitely justifiably so but then
some of it gets a little oh my God I
know I know it's a jump scare this is
his main phone that shows up I don't
know if they changed it but like I have
no problem believing anything anyone
says about this man man
yeah I mean he was kind of interesting
when he came out because he was
he has this kind of effortless way of
communicating and he he was he's a good
communicator and he seems to have some
good ideas at least he did and he I
don't know he had an interest I remember
in the past seeing clips of him speaking
about his world view and stuff and being
like this guy seems all right you know
yeah he was he was interesting to listen
to I think
and he was very fast and seemed very
smart and witty
but what happened I don't know what
happened because surely he got uh wind
of these allegations in fact I know he
did because the story is that
he was huge I mean he was huge around
the world and especially in the UK he
was doing all the big shows there all
the time on panels and stuff and then
one day
he disappeared the reason for that
was because one of the shows dropped him
when they found out
that there were some disturbing
allegations about him let me go through
this back in the UK yeah this happened a
while a bit ago and I and I was like
2018 and I am curious to track from when
he got kind of blacklisted from UK Telly
to when he started his right-wing grift
you know what I mean because it's gotta
be like a direct almost like a
It's gotta be I vote so here's the thing
he his podcast and all that that him
starting that did coincide with all of
that but the hard right turn at least as
I perceive it uh really came about
during the pandemic that's one well
that's lines up too
it was a little bit later
but I will say that it seems like he
knew that he was getting blacklisted and
decided to Pivot to doing podcasts and
stuff around that same time because I
think he realized over the time who it
seems he was leaning into them harder
and harder yeah well it's a fee I mean
and you know about this because you've
personally experienced it but there's a
audience feedback loop that happens
there's definitely there's there's a
positive reinforcement for going more
extreme yes yeah
and then you get probably a
multi-million dollar uh offer from Ben
Shapiro to just it's probably coming
soon
oh no he oh he works on Rumble
he does his own thing he's not part of
daily wire or anything he works he's
friendly with him he has a show on
Rumble he he posts on Rumble no he has
it he has a deal with them I think oh
maybe like I'm pretty sure he has a deal
with them anyway last Friday
um grifter pseudo Guru Russell Brand
he put out a video denying the
allegations before they even came out we
put out a video an hour ago that's fire
oh that's great oh there we go what is
it called
um is that unrelated it's called it's on
his Twitter and it's so dot dot oh
that's a good that's good he knows he's
good wow
he's been entered the pantheon ukulele
yeah right the only thing better than
that is it's time to talk or yeah just a
period
his thumbnails scary dude right what the
man
chill
so anyway this is why all these the
be lying this is my language
down why is the chat gbt logo in the
corner
oh sorry that's because I screenshotted
it I have a plugin from chat oh what
wait what from chechi BT how did it do
that the generator for you
no I I have on YouTube I have like a
plug-in that it's an overlay oh you just
click it you screenshot it yeah yeah ice
cream from my YouTube that's where it's
not it we're on the same page now yeah
so we put out a video before this
article dropped one day before and
you're like oh dude this guy's in some
deep because this is a wild ass
video to put out and
um here it is let's watch it
in the same posture this man has one oh
my God he's just he's like David dobrik
is just one thing boom
it's me just explaining something super
deep to you right now you need to listen
up right now
that's a mansplain pose
dude that's crazy
look at this it's the same pose as the
UFO guy it's the same it's the same
this guy looks more put together frankly
[Music]
um
all right let's watch
hello there you go title is so this is
happening
[Music]
nice tricky
there it is now this isn't the usual
type of video we make on this channel
you could say that again attack and
undermine the news in all this
corruption because in this story dude
he's already like
just
um buttering up the lunatics I don't do
this usual thing like calling out the
dog media Liars they're all liars
right guys
I am the news I've received two
extremely disturbing letters or a letter
and an email one from a mainstream media
TV company one from a newspaper listing
a Litany of extremely egregious and
aggressive attacks that sounds bad he's
like a whole list
like maybe it was just one person and
he's like listen that's it's I don't
remember it the way she had a litany
because they're not they're not making
up that would be they gotta have
sources a litany a series of petitions
for use Insurance well that's not what
that means a tedious recital or
repetitive series that's gotta be that's
a whole bunch
that's like 20.
excuse me
as well as some pretty stupid stuff like
uh my community Festival should be
stopped that I shouldn't be able to
attack mainstream media this was funny
too he goes I got a Litany of
accusations some of them were really
stupid
the other ones
God he looks nuts man
this is gonna be interesting to watch
the what happens I think this is getting
so bad I think even the the grifters are
gonna have to drop them based on the new
evidence that came out today which I
haven't heard yet but it's a recording
of him bragging about exposing himself
to a worker and in the bathroom or
something right
so that's going to be hard to to deny
Paul Jones it was him on the radio
saying it man so I I'm looking forward
to hearing that all right Dave's on this
channel but amidst this Litany of
astonishing rather Baroque attacks are
some very serious alligators I mean
again can we really deny a litany he's
like there's hordes and hordes of women
accusing me of sexual misconduct I mean
there's so many of them it's just like I
could basically just roll out a scroll
there's so many names on the record
talking to reporters
um
what's the chance is one or two of them
aren't lying then
just statistically so I absolutely
refute
these allegations pertain to the time
when I was working in the mainstream
when I was in the newspapers all the
time when I was in the movies
expensively in my books I was very very
promiscuous
dude he is not doing a good defense here
he's like yes and I had sex with lots of
fan girls and lots of random people
during the time that I got this Litany
of accusations but I swear to you guys I
swear to you 100 women they're all lying
dude
he's incriminating himself in my opinion
I saw this video I was like man he did
that for sure
now during that time of promiscuity the
relationships I had were absolutely
always consensual I was always
transparent about I guess you probably
thought that maybe I don't know well
there's direct evidence to counter that
okay then yeah never mind
giving you too much of the benefit is
out there
back then almost too transparent and I'm
being transparent about it now as well I
was too transparent he says my
relationships were consensual too
consensual
I mean I got more consent than I needed
much of a gentleman yeah yeah
I got like 200 consent
and to see that transparency
metastasized into something criminal
that I absolutely deny makes me question
is there another agenda at play of
course there must be
litany
oh this is so pathetic
this pivot is so pathetic man so
transparent particularly when we've seen
coordinated media attacks before like
with Joe Rogan when he dared to take a
medicine that the mainstream media
didn't approve of who's not canceled who
still has his deal who's basically you
face no repercussions not the same as a
sexual assault much different much well
this is a crime
this is a many crimes he's been accused
of
and by many people
also
why would I even bring that up that's so
not the same because he's you know he's
trying to win over the dummies the Rogan
and it works I mean it works
also I I hate to break it to you Russell
but I don't think you're that important
like
we've got to take out Russell Brand man
he's getting too close to the crew
like I just don't I just don't own
career narrative that the media came up
with dude he's tinting dangerous man how
many views he get on Rumble last week we
gotta take him out
and we saw a Spate of headlines from
media Outlets across the world using the
same language I'm aware that you guys
have been saying in the comments for a
while watch out Russell they're coming
for you you're getting too close to the
truth Russell Brand did not kill himself
I know that a year ago there was a space
he then hey if he shows up dead he did
not kill himself for the record I am not
suicidal I want to say that for the
record articles Russell Brown's a
conspiracy another famously very
innocent man uh once said
wait who said that that was Jesse
Smollett the guy that takes the hate
crime yeah
right not the best uh illusion there to
make uh let's take a look at uh Russell
Brand who's getting too close to the
Russell too close to the truth brand on
Rumble he's got I mean his last
eight days ago 120 000 views but bro
look at your thumbnail what are you
doing dude oh Bill Gates is doing
what your fruit now
bro is your brain that rotted wait is
that the whole thing is that the Ryan
Kavanaugh story that he was like
there's all kinds of conspiracies
because he owns all the farmlands yeah I
think it's different
but it's all Bill Gates Farmland stuff
which is a pretty good it's pretty
excuse my pun fertile topic yeah
thank you there you go thank you Zach
I'll take it thank you take a trim shot
for that
Golf Club
oh come on it's your birthday
there it is there it is
the crowd has gone wild no but is this
kind of like shockingly like bottom of
the barrel crazy yeah
what that's where we're at that's where
we're at oh Bill Gates is doing
what two fruit now what is he doing
it yeah
[Laughter]
so yeah this got a hundred and uh 20 000
views so so they got together and they
said we got to take them out
he's ruining everything
Russell Brands right wing I'm aware of
news media making phone calls sending
letters to people I know for ages and
ages it's been clear to me or at least
it feels to me like there's a serious
and concerted agenda to control these
kind of spaces and these kind of voices
yeah I know what that the U.N came
together well the globalist means like
no because he was saying that it's like
Media news around the world
are all having things like well they
think it's a central conspiracy by
globalists um
basically to control everybody on Earth
so that I guess we can create one New
World Order which is right well I think
one country one would be good
you know let's do it that's the
Socialist dream right it sure is Star
Trek it's the international baby let's
skip ahead man let's go no Gods no
borders no guys no borders baby
no problems no Gods no borders no
problem along with your voice I don't
mind them using my books and my stand up
to talk about my promiscuous consensual
you seem really funny they're
promiscuous stuff I don't know book he's
saying it too lightly he's he's like
yeah too freely I so many women
when I was famous yeah it's like okay
can you unpack that right instead of
talking about the fake media like surely
the fact that you were so promiscuous at
the height of your face you already said
it twice
gotta be gotta be
he's just lining them up outside his
hotel room next it's like I was just a
player what can I say conduct in the
past well I seriously refute are these
very very serious criminal allegations
whose evidence directly contradicts The
Narrative dude how scared is he because
people started to go into jail for this
like I mean look at uh the date
though the 70s Show guy Dan Masterson
his asses went to jail for old
accusations yeah the other thing I
should say is that this um investigation
was done jointly between three different
Global media outlets in the UK well here
my point is that it was done by three
different media Outlets over the uh over
the course of four years they were
investigating him and in the UK
unlike here in the United States the
libel laws are extremely stringent right
and so for three Publications to go out
and publish this very detailed report
about what happened between him and all
these women like if they don't want to
get sued into the ground by
Russell Brand they had to dot every eye
and cross every team so I mean obviously
we don't
these are allegations
I guess there's a small percent chance
that it's no no but no read my
lip he did that uh I'm kidding
doesn't seem that hard to believe and
the joke uh I really would be shocked if
these uh Publications did not do very
very thorough vetting on all of this so
yeah I mean yeah and the fact they did
in the UK is awesome like Reddit like
bro you can't ever go back home dude but
I love the fact that like because so
many people reported on it instead of
that making it way more valid oh yeah
for him that says it's a conspiracy
against him right right however he can
but yeah they all came together it's the
globalist agenda they have a narrative
yeah that's what happened
is that these two mainstream media
Outlets are trying to construct
apparently in what seems to me to be a
coordinated attack definitely
coordinated
it is a coordinated attack I mean not an
attack yeah no they coordinated that
over the course of four years it's
literally coordinated yeah I mean that's
they kind of admit that to you when they
sure sounds like
team effort
there's a lot of work I mean like you
said you were very promiscuous there's a
Litany of women to talk to so as you can
imagine it takes a lot of work
I don't want to get into this any
further because of the serious nature of
the allegations but I feel like I'm
being attacked and plainly they're
working very closely together we are
obviously going to look into this matter
because it's very very serious in the
meantime I've had so sweet
enough with the
you've got to get a new thing man maybe
in prison you'll learn a new thing I
don't know they have probably more it's
like they all listen to One podcast of a
guy saying what looks powerful or
something yeah they went to how they all
do this yeah being attacked and
plainly they are working very closely
together they are obviously look into
this matter because it's very very
serious don't sound serious when you say
Mata
in the meantime I want you to stay close
thank you yes that's what I'm saying
stay awake but more importantly stay
awake stay awake please stay awake not
unlike some of my victims not woke but
awake can I say that huh stay awake like
unlike some of my victims no probably
not are they button it I don't know if
Russell Brand will probably got bigger
fish to fry right now right I was just
making a joke I don't know if it was
like oh yeah sensitive for our viewers I
don't care about Russia yeah I don't
think there was any uh drug involved I
think okay well let's find out so he put
this video and everyone's like oh man
this is this is intense and this is the
video that all the people tweeted like
he's yes that's crazy because my my
first thinking and we put an album
together of all the that
defended him before the article came out
yeah and I just kept thinking to myself
like even if you're part of this Griff
Circle
let's hedge our bets and just read the
article first yeah maybe the gold office
for a second you know
um it's coming out just wait but no uh
everybody was quick to Virtue signal uh
uh uh frankly Elon Musk had a comment to
make which didn't really make that much
sense interestingly
he responded of course
they don't like competition
which I assume means like competition
the libs don't want right wing huge
right-wing personalities like Russell
uh yeah he's talking about the
mainstream media he's like the the media
doesn't want competition dude you're a
hundred thousand views on Rumble is
really threatening the established uh
media companies man
we're gonna take him out
he's getting too close to the truth did
you hear Bill Gates is doing what to our
fruits
so
um Tucker of course coming out
criticizing drug companies questioning
the war in Ukraine and you can be sure
this is going to happen yeah it's been
going to happen for four years
how long have Ukraine's been going what
like a year two year and a half that
doesn't really line up there Tucker
Tucker but you are quite dumb don't
expect anything less
Russell uh Andrew Tate Matrix attack
thank you what I tweeted out at this
point when I saw Andrew Tay I saw Tucker
and Elon Musk I said this is practically
a confession at this point
you know you might want to hide those
replies
yes I love that Tucker believes the
guy who smoked crack with Obama so
easily yeah
that's a good point very good that's a
really good point he's got a good radar
for the truth
crackhead it's actually worse he was so
very willing to breasts believe the
crackhead but he is hasn't even heard
these accusations yet and he's already
willing yeah to dismiss yo this bracket
is very credible yeah let's listen to
him
that story is amazing man I don't know
if you were here when we were talking I
was yeah yeah
feel the lie detector test yes beautiful
not that I believe in lie detectors but
they do these people do
um let's see here God hates Liars Ian
miles I don't know how to say his last
name you just call him wrong that's what
I learned that from Hassan
wrong even miles wrong because he's
always wrong about everything dude he
has the best he has the best grift like
he figured out that he can run these
right wing grifters he he lives in
Indonesia I think it's I think it's oh
Malaysia is my bad yeah he doesn't he
doesn't even live here I think he's not
a citizen is he
of the United States yeah my
understanding is he has never even been
to the end he's never even been here yet
he's so he's all he does is tweet about
U.S politics he's so fascinated it's all
he talks about is U.S politics from a
very radical right-wing perspective and
all these guys they love him they're
retweeting him all the time this man has
never been here you don't even go here
you don't go to this school he and he
that what's funny is he was recently
tweeting about the American education
system right like she's never
participated but what who is he's just a
Twitter guy he's just a dude on Twitter
and then recently he was bragging on
Twitter about how he's making like tens
of thousands of dollars from Elon Musk
program to pay to tweet and he lives in
Malaysia and I'm pretty sure the cost of
living there is is quite a bit lower
than here in America and so he's
probably living like a king on this
grift he's he's doing very well with
this that's crazy and he's smart because
he's not gonna make that money on left
on the left you know elon's paying
it man it's awesome
thank you him to tweet yeah because he
started doing this rev share with people
which makes no sense the cost of living
Malaysia is 71 less expensive
damn let's move the podcast in Malaysia
oh individual then dude I'm Outsourcing
my crew is about to be in Malaysian I'm
about to hire Ian
wait Outsource yeah I'm gonna have my
crew in Malaysia know well why don't we
just go there you wanna move there sure
no 71 reduction in cost of living
content house let's go for it
yo yo Ian come over
by the way is his name Ian is his name
Ian miles probably not I have I I
honestly don't know probably not I don't
know Ian
um Ian miles uh wrong rants about the
American lifestyle but understands it so
little that he never had a Dairy Queen
Blizzard he's never seen them flip it
upside down or had ice cream down the
side of his car because their machine
was broken this is America wait what
what did I just read I had aneurysm let
me start over
he's pointing out that he saw this GIF
of Biden turning a blizzard upside down
which like it's something Pharisee he's
confused because
anything like because he doesn't know
anything about America exactly
they do that at Dairy Queen it's
supposed to be it's so thick that you
can turn it upside down and it won't
spill out and though if you ask them to
they'll do that for you so he's doing a
thing which if you you know grew up in
America you most likely know about okay
and he's pointing out that this guy who
all he talks about is America all right
let me try this again used as in
Miles wrong rants about the American
lifestyle but understands it so little
that he's never had a Dairy Queen
Blizzard he's never seen them flip it
upside down or had ice cream down the
side of his car what does that mean
when they hand it to you through the
drive-through window oh I guess I'm not
dairy queened up you're not Derek you're
not you're not DQ pilled enough I'm not
salt to the Earth like y'all Dairy Queen
Wizards
that is America to me right America that
is yeah but that's a good point he's
just he's I don't want a blizzard guy he
really I've never had it
do we have a Dairy Queen Sam
I used to make it go find a Dairy Queen
we've never been to a Dairy Queen I
don't even know where you're getting
there oh it's so fire they're fairly
rare in Southern California there are
some around though there are some there
was one in my town of Ventura I know and
it was in a really weird strip mall so I
never went to it
what do you get there ice cream yeah
yeah they make like blizzies
but it's a fast food restaurant too like
they have like Burgers and Fries yeah
what struck me as odd what I mean
McDonald's has ice cream too you go in
there and it's like fully an ice cream
place and then you're like okay
there's like four items that is America
to me call it cream I I've had their
stuff maybe once so this is gonna be a
new experience for me but I remember
they also do this thing with the vanilla
uh ice cream that they dip in the
chocolate oh yeah that's that's cool it
hardens yeah I used to work at ice cream
I would have loved that in uh high
school and I we hated the
blizzards we hated making the blizzards
they were always the hardest to make
those are the ones you blend with the
ingredients yeah that's what I want you
know what you know what Blizzard's my
favorite blizzard wolf you're right here
quit turning me upside down Joe
yeah beautiful okay so there's not one
oh well let's get ice cream I want ice
cream there is one but it would take way
too long two hours you know how long
it's not that different than over an
hour McFlurry for an hour it's not that
though it's gonna melt by like before
McDonald's it's already four I mean we
we'll probably leave in an hour to be
just being realistic there's there's
plenty of other things that are closer
that we can get in an hour McDonald's
there's a lot of things that are under
like 30 minutes let's go okay I'll send
some options let's go baby let's dip
that I don't know so anyway I didn't
even read Ian's comment I'd ever give
you all that backstory he says they come
for us all eventually I stand with you
who's coming for you you live in
Malaysia or even are you I don't even
know where to find you I don't even know
if I can go to your country because I'm
hold on uh dual citizen I don't think
Israelis can go to Malaysia Indonesia
that might be Indonesia oh I know that I
know it's like we had a friend maybe and
I think we talked about it right it's
Malaysia or Indonesia or both malicious
well he lived in Indonesia so I know
that but let's see a quick Google search
says you're right um they're restricted
at the moment okay they're not
Outsourcing the boys I'm not coming for
you I can't even get in never mind Jews
he's like come get me if you can oh
basically there's a lot of the um
Arab states that just to Israelis are
like nah
no thanks not you no thanks
which I get I guess Malaysia's or what
because there's there's mad tension but
Malaysia it was a surprise to me
I was like
Malaysia
um
y'all are way over what are you playing
I'm trying to understand the strawberry
somebody you keep hitting are you saying
nah he keeps saying nah
okay usually I'm with uh okay yeah I get
it now I was a little confused on that
one they all come for us eventually I
stand with you that's such an awesome
blank check to give someone before you
read the article
I stand with you brother
okay Ian
so this guy's the best so here's all the
defending him was Ben Shapiro
and none of those morons involved Jordan
I saw it Jordan Peterson was defending
him before the article came out
I did not
like I'm pretty sure there was a lot
more we had a little clip of Ben Shapiro
we put in here somewhere let me find it
but I know it's impossible to find
Jordan Peterson tweets on the timeline
by Googling something about Russell he
he definitely responded before yeah I
remember that he retweeted the article
said they're coming for you oh right
yeah yeah Gordon so he he just signal
boosted it I thought it was so funny
because he just retweeted the article
yeah
I don't think that's what you're
supposed to do if you're defending your
homie yeah so everybody can read this a
gaming article I don't think the Giants
Jordan preemptively defended it was just
this I know for sure he didn't read the
article because it was really well
sourced yeah here it is yeah someone
wants him destroyed article please read
this it's like oh okay which I thought
because if people do read this they'll
realize that if you read it it's very a
good article yeah okay all right Howie
anyway like sometimes you read some
articles and there's a little room for
doubt this is not one of those times
yeah
this is not it
yo this ice cream is looking pretty
interesting right now it looks so good
because ice cream is speaking to my soul
at this moment
are you what are you saying that like
you're not gonna get it I want
everything dude okay so your problem you
were saying it like you were gonna yeah
I said it's not here I can't eat all of
them love you should get the pear and
blue cheese ice cream
here yeah it's on there man shame on
them for that
foreign
just write what you want
they just have sprinkles do I mix stuff
in or is it just is it just it's not a
mix-in type place you just pick a flavor
yeah you just I think you can get up to
like three flavors if you want all
different kind of flavors oh what what
about the cones because I like the cone
but that seems like a psychotic thing to
deliver maybe they do give you the cone
separately we can order just a box of
Cups that's true we can just because I
love the cone or waffle bowls if they
have I love me a cone we could just
order pints of flavors and then make do
the cone here
I don't know what to tell these people I
mean this this is incredible chocolate
mocha you know sea salt with caramel
ribbon what did I say to that question I
think just get a bunch of which one
they're Fried Chicken all different
flavors Fried Chicken yeah cinnamon and
honey Fried Chicken what yeah no they
make really oh my God out there but
it's really good chocolate potato salad
I've never seen that huh I didn't guess
that might be good pinot porched poached
pear sherbet that sounds kind of
interesting huh
The Salted malt salted malted chocolate
chip is what is this one berries and
farts what what that's I don't doesn't
sound appetizing what
says dingleberries and nuts no way
that's disgusting
this one says nipple hair and cream
that's crazy
I'd eat it yeah here's Big Boy this
one's called Gooch Grease
Gooch Cruise
Joe Rogan bath water
I guess I'll I'll give you my order
which is just mint and Chip you know no
I need mint and Chip and the and the
Salted Caramel Ribbon why don't I just
get a bunch of pints and Cones yeah I
think we should do that that's a lot of
work man I mean I'll I can do it I just
need I just need to be because okay
yeah do whatever is easier
okay all right I don't like having like
unlimited amount of ice cream though
absolutely I like to have a finite
amount of ice cream yeah I'll take it
home don't worry
be hide it you'll take it home
Ian will not let me take that home
he's the ice cream I won't say I'll take
it home but then you'll have it at home
too so yeah I've been good but dude I
can't the ice cream's the one thing like
yeah I don't know how good I've been on
my diet I don't care how dedicated how
much I've been through I'm gonna eat I
donate it then because I don't have that
problem with ice cream I volunteer I can
forget it there for months
I'll protect that drives me crazy
I'll take it like I'll block out and put
it in my bag
I just you know what I mean that's why I
want the person ice cream soup in your
bag yo what the is this Flavor now
I know that this
is what I think it is cummies I have
different flavors
that's weird I'll try it
gummies with sprinkles
all right well I gave you my flavor so
do whatever you want with them or did I
thank you
all right where were we Russell Rebrand
Jordan Peterson Russell Rebrand himself
as a grifter yeah I think that was uh I
think that was a den original you said
that already he's not here I'll take
credit
just gonna steal his labor real fast
because steal his jokes
yeah we saw that already thank you sir
so um
so anyway the exposed turned out to be
three-pronged attack from three UK
Outlets the Sunday Times the times and
channel 4 dispatches a dateline like
show yo so I don't know anything about
the UK Publications I'm assuming these
are all pretty big reputable uh names
and UK media yeah they're very big
Okay so
yeah sounds really suspicious but let me
summarize the article for you
um he's accused of r word essay and
emotional abuse by multiple women during
a seven year period when he was at the
peak of his Fame he's accused of our
word yes
yeah no wonder you're so scared I'm
out here trying to do this
he's he might go to jail it sounds like
it sounds like he should or I don't know
what what's like in the UK because Jimmy
Savelle was like he died a hero but in
America they're has he not has he not
been living in the U.S though I think he
did escape to the United States I don't
think he's in the UK no although I don't
know where does he oh some of it I think
even most of these allegations happened
in here in L.A yeah so he so if he's so
he'll be he'll be going to prison here
he'd be tried I mean if it gets looked
into now that it's been exposed I will
just have to find out it's only been
like a week
let's see he
he just one day ago
oh oh somebody said the documentary is
very tough to watch I want wait they
released a video documentary about it
yeah yeah well that's the dispatchers
thing that's what oh that's a TV yeah
yeah that's a can you write the name of
that I don't want to forget I'm in need
I'm gonna need my VPN bro if you use
expressvpn you can VPN to the UK and
watch it for I don't want to say for
free I don't because I just don't a lot
of times sure but I think so dude a lot
of times you can't even watch in America
and what's up with the free market there
like how failed is that free market that
I can't get the British you talking well
because it's uh it's uh BBC is publicly
funded and so you're not paying for it
but then then why can't I watch it
it's because the UK taxpayers are paying
for it and they're like us and nobody
else
is they doing for the public that's
up you know what I mean Norway
get it off the screen maybe some of our
uh British fans can
um clarify this for us but that's my
understanding of
why the BBC is not available
[Music]
laughs
so in the article he's accused of okay
the chat's confirming if you it's free
in the UK so if you can find your way to
the UK internet you can watch the
documents but why but then like the
American audience is going to want to
know about this
the crimes happened here what's up
what's the queen up to what's King
Charles doing about it
oh people are saying it's on Channel 4
which isn't BBC oh okay I thought it was
a BBC uh uh program what's channel four
it's just another station in the UK is
it on YouTube maybe they uploaded it uh
they have a website that you can watch
on I'm on it right now I can stream it
okay it says you have to register
man get my info unimportant Jeff Dunham
aol.com I'm registering right now to
check to see if you can watch it for
free in America I'm registering
an important announcement Buckingham
Palace has announced the death of her
majesty Queen Elizabeth Queen Elizabeth
would have made this available for
everybody King Charles is
the pooch man
those sausage figures just can't hold on
to anything
flipping Four Women including one who is
only 16. what have alleged essay that
occurred between 2006 2013.
three alleged victims extensively shared
their experience with the journalists
through interviews and provided
substantial supporting evidence
I wonder if anyone who who um
was like he's he man they're all coming
for us I got your back and then they
start reading this like oof maybe I
should have read this first yep
at least one probably did
she said they met up in June 2012 at his
house in LA
and went on to have consensual sex
but she was unsettled by his glazed over
look
yeah he does this thing when he claims
it's over bro is he Mormon he might be
it might be you might be going
Scientology they realized and he's in
L.A right okay I don't know what's going
on his head when he glazes over like
this it was fine but it was a weird
first time experience with someone when
you're having sex with them for the
first time
okay it's like a drug for him I think
when you're a sex addict I guess they
met again in the early hours of the
morning July 1st when she arrived at his
house after he had pleaded with her to
come over
they then met again in the earliest
hours wait I'm sorry where after acting
erratically and asking for her to
participate in a threesome with someone
he allegedly forced himself on her
without a condom after she turned him
down oh
the classic you can sense at once hmm
that's a sick freak dude
um what's with the threesome thing I've
noticed that before with these guys
um so this this woman Nadia provided
receipts for her text Exchange in the
immediate aftermath of the encounter
now Jordan Peterson you might want to
read these
here is a verified text Exchange
um he said I'm sorry that was crazy and
selfish I hope you can forgive me I know
that you're a lovely person
she said
you scared the out of me you're
right I'm a lovely person and for you to
take advantage of me like that is
unexpected or unexpectable or just you
wanted to stay unacceptable yeah you
have a problem you need help it's
dangerous that you think you can get
your own way all the time do you know
how scary you are when you glaze over
look comes over you
when a girl says no it means no do I
have to go and get myself tested
last time you asked me condom or no
condom and when I say condom that
doesn't mean it's optional you don't
have the best reputation I pry myself on
being safe and trying to make the right
decisions obviously this was a bad one
I'm so disappointed he responded to that
even
I'm very sorry you don't need to get
tested I will make this up to you
somehow with live with life and kindness
not my original idea of what was more
sex
oh what
wait hold on I'm very sorry you don't
need to get tested I will make this up
to you somehow
with live love maybe love a love and
kindness not my original idea which he
was going to pay her back with more sex
dad which was more sex you've been
lovely to me and I'm embarrassed by my
behavior
will you ever forgive me he messaged her
again
this is from July 1st and then he
messaged in August 5th and says will you
ever forgive me
of course pretty bad Jordan
Peterson I mean that's like
that's all it's all right there there's
not even
Jordan Peterson oh who's red this
there's not even anything in question
really
come read this guys
he's one of us
he's one of us it's an attack he said
I'll be there with you at Russell Brand
Jordan Peterson said that he said I'll
be there with you yeah but he wants to
be there next time
what like he's predicting they're gonna
come for him yeah
I want to be with you next time you do
that Russell
Jordan Pearson said that
or is it an admission that he knows some
some stuff is going to come up about him
too they're friends let me cross
reference the dates because he said so
much about him
his Twitter feed is hard to parse
Jordans that is
his Jordan's Twitter feed is the glimpse
into a very sick mind dude you remember
that movie it was with Jennifer Lopez
where they they were like cops and they
found a way to go in criminals brains no
try to uncover oh the cell I love that
movie that's like one of my favorite
like that's good one of my favorite like
seven out of 10 movies ever I've never
seen and you know what I mean like it's
like it's not like it's got like it's
pretty some weirdness about it but it's
a very cool movie so his brain is like
the inside of the cell our Twitter is
like inside this song sorry you know who
the male lead in that movie was
I don't remember Vince Vaughn
is that right yes it was kind of cool
back then I guess it was like before he
was even known in like comedy movies and
stuff
it was a really artsy movie where they
were like flying and it was quite
it's all the dream sequences were super
cool I mean the imagery was awesome
here it is the cell you should try it
out
yeah and the role of a lifetime JLo
anyway I said Tanger we don't need to go
down
too late though we're doing donut
should I hit the button
I didn't hear what you said so maybe
yeah no I'm kidding it was a joke button
has anybody even listen to me I was
reading the next story I was curious
what else he's accused of and uh just to
clarify when he shall be with you he's
referring to some rumble debate 2024 so
I guess it wasn't this specific
situation I'll be in that cell with you
brother
anyway moving on
um the US phone number that bran used to
send the messages has been verified by
multiple sources
Nadia meanwhile
had a close friend and what had happened
told a close friend what had happened
and she took her to get a rape treatment
to a rape treatment Senate at UCLA Santa
Monica Medical Center that same day wow
that's always what they say is like
where's the proof when you get the kit
she did that she did do that yeah she
got the text and she's got she went to
the center
and on the same day she told a friend
about it
uh oh sounds she's pretty verified you
mean what what uh oh like what else can
you say in his defense I have no idea
literally nothing just that they're come
for us all brother well I don't know did
you rape someone
Ian
question I mean emails uh wrong emails
wrong
oh not you Ian not you oh not you again
all right new sound bite no I'm kidding
you didn't rape anyone right Ian no no I
didn't think so let's talk him out uh
he's giving you the button yeah turn the
button around on you okay sorry about
that Ian
God
Ian's Ian's a consensual King you have
to say the full name when you're not
talking about Disney yeah I know
um
she shared a full copy of her treatment
records which states that she was
provided her underwear and some other
samples as evidence wow which were
frozen an officer from the Los Angeles
Police Department was alerted by the
Senate according to notes and she chose
not to make a police report saying that
the center she didn't think my words
would mean anything up against his the
notes also state that she was worried
that if her assailant name is somehow
released that her name would get dragged
through the dirt and she's right about
that
what's interesting is it doesn't seem
like
she has any and again the other things
like oh they want Cloud she wanted money
I don't see I don't really even see a
much of a
path to even make that bad faith of an
argument I mean she she didn't say
anything about it until she was
contacted presumably by these
journalists
and she didn't say anything about it
then and as far as I know she didn't
ever ask him for money
try to sue him personally
this is about as like clean iron clad
yeah cases I've ever seen he did that
and and like it's all there I don't
know neither coming for us all Jordan's
got his back
so now do we have tweets of people after
the article came out we have not just
yeah if you keep going because this is
so I'm telling you this whole story is
phenomenal and I don't mean that like
you know what I mean it's just yeah so
Illuminating about the right wing yeah
uh how they shelter each other Nadia had
therapy at the clinic for the following
five months during her therapy sessions
records show that Nadia was
contemplating criminal or civil
proceedings before ultimately citing
against it however she wrote brand a
letter hoping to regain some of her
power in the process uh her note said
and she says she sent it to his house
that seems like a honest yeah no
ulterior motive man you even got the
text from him boy stop right now
another woman Alice says she had a
three-month relationship when she was
16.
which ended shortly after her alleged
assault by brand note that this was in
the UK where the illegal age of consent
is 16. God God saved the queen
or whatever that's a joke
what should I hit the button oh okay
you were yikesing him right yeah yeah
because I didn't do anything I just made
a joke yeah yeah thank you and he was in
his early 30s
yeah yeah
that's so nice that's gross
oh Jordan just retweeted his new video
by the way so he has his phone he stands
with him this PhD doctor
of Psychiatry psychology
he has his full support
is it are you uh are you screening in
Amy are you watching that video I
started it but I got a sidetracked
because we're
there's no way we're gonna have time but
I'm definitely gonna watch over the
weekend it's three minutes oh oh his new
video that's what I meant oh yeah I
definitely want to watch that yeah yeah
I go oh you want me watching now here
let me just get through this no no I
think we should do it at the end for
sure so
um no this was in the UK Bram was in his
early 30s that time bran referred to her
as the child asked her to read Vladimir
no boat
Cobbs Lolita he asked her to do that
and kosher on what to say to her parents
when he wanted to see her no he did not
say that that is not true that's grew up
that's grooming yeah that is grooming
that's that's grooming and everything
that's like that's true that is
absolutely what it is yo you guys are
defending a groomer right now and that's
not even debatable
they're like man these groomers are I'm
telling you there's like groomers and
they oh Russell come come come on anyway
man there's groomers everywhere come
come everybody come come
anyway the kids are in the basement man
there's groomers everywhere
Alice was over the age of consent in the
UK she and her family members who have
also spoken to the Sunday Times to
corroborate her story both describe
Brand's Behavior as quote grooming
um
he asked her to read Lolita that's so
weird
Alice says he suggested how she could
deceive her parents into allowing her to
visit him and claims that he gave her
scripts on how to lie to them she also
alleges that he told her not to trust
her friends and that they would all be
looking to make money from it if she
revealed she was seeing him it was
isolating she said
towards the end of the relationship
Alice says that brand essayed her she
says I was sat up in the bed against the
headboard
so uh just heads up if you uh don't want
to hear this I mean maybe I don't even
need to read the specifics yeah you
assaulted her yeah he assaulted her
uh yeah he assaulted violently we should
say I mean obviously there's always yeah
but like shoot he was chilling yeah he
hurt her and she had to push him off him
yeah
uh Alice has decided to speak up because
she now believes that she was too young
to be able to consent to a relationship
with an adult man and that the law
should be changed to protect those under
18. I mean listen
I think the age of consent at 16 is fine
as long as the people you're having sex
with are like you know your age
because that's just that's just gonna
happen because I think it's crazy when
like somebody who just turned
first you have a bigger issue with the
large age Gap the age Gap yeah right
that and I do think some places have
that where they're like 16 plus or minus
like two years or something oh I think a
lot of places do actually yeah which
makes sense to me but I guess not in the
UK sometimes you hear like based off of
how this is you have a 17 year old girl
with a eight-year-old boyfriend and they
might even be five months a difference
and then the boyfriend goes to jail for
like statutory
which seems pretty nuts to me but I I
don't know anything specifically I've
just heard about stuff like that
but anyway
The Fallout has been Swift are people
gonna get mad at me for that I feel like
that's a reasonable tick no you're fine
thank you
thanks
no worries
nobody's had sex at 16.
I'm defending myself against another
accusation having to be made
um I stand this is really good cam this
is actually a nice campaign for him I
stand with races oh it says allege yeah
thank you for adding that
we stand with our friends man wow
powerful
love that so the fallout's been Swift
YouTube demonetized his channel
he had now I at first I was like I've
never seen YouTube act like that
strongly to an allegation yeah I don't
remember but now that I've read the
article and like there's it's like oh he
definitely he did do that and I have to
imagine that he was on thin ice with
YouTube
as it is potentially with all like the
coven yeah misinfo stuff and all that
like he had to be close as it was yeah
so they're just like nah dude not you no
more
um and what's interesting about that is
if you go to his YouTube channel he was
pulling pretty good numbers there so I
think that was a significant financial
hit to him not that I think he's poor by
any means he's probably quite wealthy
but
what no I don't think you clicked it
well let me refresh I think I did oh you
saw how easy that was you guys oh they
got you okay I have a theory that all
this like I YouTube unsubbed me and all
this it's like that yeah me too
interesting you see how easy that was
that was nuts bro why they had also a
visual bug that it said you were
subscribed so when you actually clicked
it you haven't subscribed nice you know
perfect I'm sure it's stuff like that
yeah his views are I mean here's from
two months ago 1.6 million what is it
it's not easy two hours ago his new
video is popping seven days ago that's
the one about what happened 2.2 million
750 750 1 million so he was pulling to a
major uh figures here
you know
um
so I yeah uh Crowder of course had to
speak up oh Crowder this man knows how
to treat women
let's hear what he has to say
what okay sorry Crowder
so demonetized for unproven allegations
that have nothing to do with his YouTube
channel did you read the I don't know
peas and crocodiles is futile crocodiles
is that a for expression or is that like
The Velveteen eyes thing
it's amazing crocodiles is futile
crocodile tears
I don't think that applies to this are
there like crocodile circling you get a
piece of crops I've seen people do that
right yeah
Steve Irwin like you couldn't appease
maybe uh
like a shark is a shark probably it'd be
harder it'd be harder I think they're
more aggressive yeah
you could definitely appease a pool with
this test he's wrapped up well not like
that no you could abuse him by taking
those off you give them your wives good
luck trying to take those off yeah it's
hard I've never heard this as a
statement though I don't think it is I'm
fascinated by it so um Steven says it's
unproven damn did you read it though
did you read it
I like the top reply to that was Crowder
is next which I'm pretty sure they were
saying as a uh I think it was a joke he
said Crowder next like YouTube do
Crowder next no I think I could be wrong
but I think that they were
saying you know they're going to come
after the Deep state is going to come
after Crowder next
router is next and oh is that like a
genuine thing
oh it's pretty I mean they already did
right
his wife is part of the deep state by
the way
his own family man Matt Walsh of course
who is um
an expert on women
and what they are that show the
leftovers which is a great show by the
way thank you
this is insane YouTube is demonetizing
all of Bran's accounts based on unproven
allegations made in the media he hasn't
even been criminally charged with
anything the precedent being sent here
is extremely bad you know I see where
he's coming from in the sense that you
haven't read the article yet
because when you do that right yeah yeah
yeah there's not you know he did that
yeah understand what YouTube has
just done they have given the left a
blueprint for demonetizing someone yeah
but rape is in the Left Right issue
right no or I guess maybe they want I
didn't think it is well
simply accuse them of sexual assault
that's not dude that's so not what
happened
that's actually that's so funny that you
say that you so haven't read the art the
operative word here is simply it's not
simple at all it's like four years of
work
that went into this by and multiple
sounds like dozens of rape kit right
corroborations from the same day I mean
yeah okay doesn't matter if it's proven
or not they're open the floodgates
intentionally so of course a version of
this blueprint has been around for a
long time but to my knowledge this is
the first time YouTube is actually
demonetizing an account based on media
accusations that might be true actually
uh but again if you read the article
that had nothing to do with YouTube this
is an escalation I'm trying to think if
there's been anybody that got it's like
Charles Manson's been arrested uh for
murder and then they write an article
and they're like here he is with a knife
and the body in the back and they're
like dude he's only been
he's only been accused he hasn't been
proven yet in court
it's part of the left-wing agenda
um Brands management dropped him
not surprised
this guy's got a interesting sense of
style man it's like he's a cheek
yeah it's like he wants to be like oh
he's got a big ass Cross Too what
I thought he was like an atheist
I guess he found God all of a sudden he
talks about like spirituality but not
like specific to my knowledge he's like
I'd be Jesus who like a lot of
women a Litany of them wait
I was trying to think if uh
somebody else had been um demonetized
because of allegations in the media and
I'm seeing
that uh David dobrik was after The
Insider article
David dobrik David dobrik two in the
channel for his video podcast views
was it like a temporary one or yeah it
was temporary he wasn't permanently
I don't think why would it be temporary
for something like that that doesn't
make any sense that's how they've done
it with like Logan Paul no I was
wondering about James Charles too if
they ever temporary yeah that dude's
monetized
disappeared on YouTube what is the
temporary demonetization Institute like
a punishment yeah that would make sense
if it were some for something that you
did on YouTube right but like just
hearing that you're like you know a sex
criminal in the media I feel like that's
not like a a time out kind of thing
right like shouldn't that be all or
nothing yeah I see what you're saying
and um in the case of dobrik and I don't
know in dover's case but okay I'm pretty
sure James is back baby
uh tavit Tavis stock wood management has
dropped brand see you later
in 2020 the woman Alice who claimed she
was said by brand during a three-month
relationship when she was 16 contacted
his agent at the time
who's also the so-called founder
co-founder of the talent agency
in a statement Tavistock told Dateline
deadline Russell Brand categorically and
vehemently denied the allegations so
they look pretty dumb now because they
found out about this
right over three years ago and did
nothing about it they heard about it
they talked to him he said this woman I
didn't do that
and uh and they were like okay and now
this came out and it's the same woman is
uh the one that we were just talking
about the 16 year old and I'm sure that
whatever oh okay I'm sure whatever
evidence she provided to the journalist
she probably sent a good deal of it
probably yeah no they're definitely not
looking good here he's like I didn't do
it they're like okay cool I had to ask
right well I mean they obviously have a
financial incentive not to to believe
him well these big media companies are
have like I mean covering up essay of
their clients is basically like and part
of the Playbook
you know
it's business as usual all right but we
now believe oh they changed their mind
uh he denied it in 2020 but we now
believe we were horribly misled by him
we have terminated all professional ties
around what weasels yeah
I'd like to know what evidence new have
you seen that you didn't see then right
I would like to see that
oh dude we were so wrong
Weasley little liar dude I swear we we
grilled him hard we asked him a lot of
questions right like did he do it
and
like
it
that I guess that was it
I just got an ad on David's Channel and
on James's Channel yeah they're both
they're back yeah they're back
deadline released an article that
discussed how brand was booked as a
judge on comedy Central's roast battle
in 2018 but only lasted a single season
on the series after he himself was
roasted by an on-camera
uh talent I guess one of the other
judges or one of the yep over an
allegation that he had essayed a woman
that was part of the roast and then he
was on a rose show one of the other
judges roasted him on the show
for assaulting a woman
and apparently he didn't like that roast
three sources close to full well uh 73
production said roast battle judge
Catherine Ryan shout out turned the heat
on brand a number of times during
filming gives him directly of being a
predator brand is reported to have at
one point stormed offset her allegations
did not make the final cut not surprised
oh wow
no sir not surprised by that it's not
something probably but you know it's
kind of Gone Crazy to after everything
we've read so far to think back about
the video that he posted before this
came out right oh yeah like the way he's
acting in that video this is outrageous
completely face yeah it's just
like an inside God man I'm telling you
crazy wait till you see the news
oh boy you admitted in the first text
already that what happened is true so he
goes please forgive me like three years
later please forgive me
uh here's um a clip of Katherine Ryan I
guess that's her talking about
what is allegedly him
what in retrospect is pretty obviously
uh yeah nine months ago so this is
before this report came out that's where
to open in a pop-up blocked it
okay I got it
so this is the girl who's roasting him
and you believe as a predator yeah
I mean like what am I supposed to I
thought about that
do I do it yeah it's such a messy thing
because like I don't have proof
I see you girl
so
um
she told luthero on a recent episode of
his interview oh
fast is he working on something he's
very okay
wait what happened that was really fast
yeah I guess here let me do like this
um She's accused of very prominent
British TV personally being a predator
yeah she told Louis row in a recent
episode of his interview series that the
man's behavior is an Open Secret
not according to him
and um though she didn't divulge his
name saying it's very dangerous for us
to have this conversation
not anymore open your heart girl
um roast battle was a Brand's last
significant reoccurring role in the UK
he had appeared on channel 4's the great
celebrity Bake Off who now put out uh
the documentary about him
channel four not not the celebrity bake
off no no but the same network but other
bookings have been rare despite his
regular appearance on Comedy and chat
shows on British TV earlier in his
career so all of a sudden he disappears
right after this is when bran reinvented
himself as a self-style counter-culture
guru questioning The Narrative of
mainstream media on social media
platforms man it's crazy how he just got
struck by this enlightening uh this yeah
he's so enlightened all of a sudden
though for the first few years on this
turn he had more of a free spirit sort
of Bohemian hippie spiritual vibe
but I guess when coven went on he went
off the rails you know how that is yada
yada
um here's an album of all of our
favorites so these are this is Post
article juice this is now after yeah so
let's take a look
what is this what is this showing me oh
oh oh no that sorry that was just to
show that like like
people said you used to do like the
hippie thing but in the last like year
or so now like if this is well he was he
was doing like Joe Rogan like I'm listen
I'm open-minded but oh yeah exactly her
arm yeah right
weirdo uh right-wing friends we have
Tucker stuff love RFK Jr of course
uh router Router didn't even want to
talk to him Dave Rubin is the one that
cracked me up the most look at that at
the bottom he was probably so stoked
Dave rubin's and married gay guy by the
way by the way 80 000 views that the
state is coming for him for sure he's
getting two oh it was the worst by far
because everyone literally everyone
hates Jay Rubin nobody likes Dave Rubin
not even Dave Rubin doesn't like Dave
Rubin
um
here's a link of his video page on
YouTube yeah we we know another one was
come forward uh with a further
allegation the woman says it happened in
2008 when she was working in the same
building as the bvtv in Los Angeles she
encounter left her son she said minutes
later he was recorded laughing with his
co-presenter who said brand showed his
Willy to a lady
bran has not yet commented on this this
is a new allegation yeah so I wonder if
that's what the or like yesterday or
something but yeah I wonder if that's
what the new video is about so so here
actually and again
in here's the
here's the clip pull the clip so this
this first one this clip is her talking
about it so you watch this first and
then when you scroll down you can hear
the clip go look for the clip from the
video show perfect thank you someone
behind me so at that stage I was
squatting and I turned around and in my
eyesight was a man's groin in black
pants
so I was startled and I got up and I
realized it was Russell
oh I think you're a bit all right and I
went okay okay and then he said I'm
going to call you Betty and I said but
that's not my name my name isn't Betty I
told him my name and he said but I'm
gonna call you Betty and I said but
that's not my name and then he said well
I'm going to you and I went what
and he goes I'm gonna you and I
said no you're not and he pulled out his
blasted penis on his hand and served it
to me as you would be serving someone
some food and I've said no no no you're
not going to me I mean there's a
bit of banter going on because I didn't
know what to do and then by which stage
his penis was put back into his pants
the door was closed behind him I'm not
sure whether he locked it or not but it
was a hundred percent closed and then
all of a sudden there was like banging
like bang bang bang like Russell you
want it Russell you're wanted in the
radio Studio it took him a while to
eventually open the door I went back to
my desk I laughed at it thinking what
just happened that shouldn't have
happened like that but who would believe
me I was stunned at the time I didn't
know what to do I then went to text the
person that was in the studio with them
to say oh my God the strangest thing
happened I went to the restroom and
Russell Brand showed me his penis to
which they replied yes I know he's
talking about it on air oh this was
played out yet in the office though wow
so others were aware about what had
happened that day it was a pre-record so
I suspect that someone back in London
would have been listening to the output
nobody has come to say sorry to me for
his behavior so I thought perhaps that
particular audio had been cut out how'd
you feel about that
listening to it now just disgusting it's
disgusting I feel ashamed but I wonder
had something been done there would have
been fewer women perhaps that he would
have done horrible things to what was
your reaction to the BBC now
investigating it's a bit late but in
through a sense of Duty
appropriate to to go out like that I
just don't understand why they didn't
investigate this much sooner so dude the
mentality of being like I'm gonna show
my dick to anybody I want and tell them
to them
like imagine what's going on in his mind
yeah and he's he's probably just doing
it with uh like I'm gonna call you Betty
when it's not even her name like what
it's just weird psycho like control
thing I guess
he really thought he was just like so
anyway so here here's
uh you know he'd be like man that didn't
happen here he is
just a few minutes later oh so Lucy
Lawless the Xena Warrior Princess
actress and also star of bedtime stories
to feel mum doing is coming down she'll
surprise you Matt because you think the
actual plan seeing the Warrior Princess
I think should be enough but Crump bit
Dolly part you'd have a big dog
lovely not good she's rappers
no she's smart as a whip
sort of but like you know where it's a
woman will respect him or something why
because she's a bit you know you need
control of herself in control of herself
you know the ones you like I don't know
this one too I won't be able to drag her
off into a cubicle and show her my
pubicles
it's been a long while Matt since old
Russian five minutes since he showed his
Willy to a lady very easy why are you
wait this is like yeah he does that but
the other guy already knows about it
sounds like it
um dude what I'm pretty sure that we
knew in 2008 that
showing your genitals to a lady that you
work with yeah in the office yeah in
addition to what he was saying too
you right I'm sure he didn't know that
but he's like yo you show my dick to
whatever her name is he sounds Wasted by
the way I don't know I know he's like
had problems with drugs before too I I
don't know if he was supposedly sober at
this point he sounded drunk as to
me though that wouldn't make sense yeah
say that it's been a long while Matt
since oh five minutes since he showed
his Willy to a lady very easy to judge
he's a general receptionist look if you
receive this I'm
[Music]
environment
again have you heard this Jordan
Peterson
okay
Maybe not maybe it was doctored I don't
know it's probably doctored must be fake
somebody I mean technology is crazy
these days man why
um even after Oracle came out
everybody's defending him check this out
Jordan Peterson tweeted out the article
we looked at that one
Alex Jones I mean there's no surprise
but
at this point I think we can all agree
that like
this is probably of all the ones I've
seen
as equal to or more or the most likes
just flat out like he this guy did all
that I mean the evidence is just
over so much evidence yeah and so Alex
Jones uh that's awesome
personally I knew him back when he was
married to Katy Perry he's come on the
show this man had to blast us out at the
airport it was so fashioned passion that
was so weird right I've never seen
women throw themselves
anybody like with him so this is such an
um
this is the craziest defense yeah like
trust me he can't rape women because
they're just throwing themselves at him
all the time yeah
Alex
it's like that okay at restaurants one
of those events I went to it was
literally women jumping at us okay and
he's a big guy in person
no one ever accused him for the last 15
years
I was soft and they say he's a big
sweetheart oh yeah because they would
come to you about it comes out against
the globalist he comes out against the
New World Order yeah
Crowder thinks that if he was a sex
freak liberal he wouldn't be getting me
to really
wasn't Weinstein that's
was like the me too guy and like
but mainstream like what about like Matt
Lauer yeah it seems like most of them
were were left a lot of them were
Charlie Rose yeah Charlie Rose
Louis C.K was definitely um I don't know
what it's called
Russell Brand like um yeah like he was
jerking off to like somebody who like
came into the room and had no idea he
was going to do that or it was it was
very simple no his stuff was good yeah I
know he had good he had high level stuff
there
though Crowder who I'm sure has read all
the Articles the conservative now but I
do know that he's spoken out against a
lot of powerful people yeah and I do
know that he's taken some risks and I do
know when you start taking risks he's a
hero certainly did take a risk when he
showed his to his co-worker no he's
actually a national hero he's a risk
taker yeah and we love that here on the
right don't we folks there's a
coordinated attack that follows this is
a pattern that we have seen quite a bit
so in this case we have all the accusers
are Anonymous okay there have been no
criminal charges there have been no
investigations I love this it's been
substantial all the accusers are
Anonymous but if they weren't Anonymous
then they'd be looking there's no
winning it doesn't matter are
insane yeah it's so stupid the
fact that they're Anonymous how is it
related it was verified behind the
scenes you know yeah that but they're
not well are they Anonymous I believe
all but one they're not putting out
their real name but clearly but it was
all verified yeah yes medical records
Medical Records I mean like actual
journalism they got notes from her
therapist at the time I read
right yeah
yours are Anonymous okay there have been
no criminal charges there have been no
investigations they are not yet dummy
thus far nothing has been substantiated
at all we haven't been provided the
public has not been provided with
anything
we just saw so much evidence sorry
Crowder not everyone could be caught on
Ringling we just saw so much you're the
only idiot exactly
that's a good point Abe but he got
pretty damn close yeah almost he walked
right up to being caught on camera we
need that ring footage or it didn't
happen ring or didn't happen
um yeah I didn't need to finish this I
mean it's like they just don't care it's
not true you guys love talking about
fake media you're not even saying the
truth they're they're pro-rape and
they're Pro grooming yeah don't care
Stephen Crowder also whipped his dick
out to co-workers good so he feels
solidarity you know what that's work or
solidarity you know what
it was dudes it was dudes being just
dudes boys will be boys and dick too
Tate defended brand who cares that's
obvious not surprising Ben Shapiro now
here's a really level-headed
conservative a lot of conservatives
look at Ben as one of the great thinkers
on level headed so let's Whip and had to
say about this yeah you can finally get
it intelligent now realizing she wasn't
fine during a relationship that lasted
for about three months when brand was a
BBC radio presenter she said she
referred to her as the child and alleges
he became increasingly controlling and
then emotionally and sexually abusive so
at this time brand was 30 and she was
apparently 16. okay now in the United
States crime in the UK not crime the age
of consent in the UK is 16 and
apparently brand ascertain at the 216 by
asking her and checking which means
scuzzied scumbaggy Behavior sure
criminal Behavior no it's still a story
well and grooming did happen and we're
ignoring the fact that that relationship
ended when he violently assaulted her
and he's ignoring that she said
yeah right but he's like listen it
wasn't well it was a crime by hers but
he's he's going it's not a crime for a
grown man to have sex with a
six-year-old in UK let's move on like
first of all that alone is a story right
I think you're you're ignoring like that
again a large part of the story these
guys are liars they don't care about
anything yeah I mean people with
conservative friends and family show
them this they don't care they're Liars
if you're again in the UK and the age of
consent changes from States I would
prefer the age of consent be 18. but
dude this is but this is but this is
almost like what Alex Jones this is like
Alex Jones said I mean this is a crazy
way to dismiss it he's like yeah
he a six-year-old but who gives a
it's not a crime there
he's a very small brain he sounds like
TTS
I'm sorry the way he talked Ben Shapiro
oh interesting yes yes like The Tick
Tock voices oh thanks he does kind of
have that that sort of thing yeah the
Cadence it sounds like an AI version of
himself yeah Eli you're gonna love the
next guy who defended him it all ties
together yeah this is full circle
no yes he is are you kidding me no I'm
not
after the allegations came out he
tweeted I guess what's with the blue
heart again the wink Wing I guess
I'm assuming I verified it I went into
Ryan's Instagram and because I I was so
blown away I was like oh this is a meme
just like on Ryan yeah so I went and
looked and it was it was up there so
this is right after I guess his video or
the article it was after the article
came out I believe so yeah I'm pretty
yeah it was after it was the same day I
don't know what time it was in
relationship okay why did he add the
heart sticker what is this yeah
I think this is somebody else's he like
restored this yeah it says somebody
else's uh that was already there what is
he talking about in the clip I found the
clip I sent it but um just to clarify he
posted this the day that Russell's
initial video came out right afterwards
everyone was already talking about it so
let's see what does he say he's just
talking about whatever to be yeah
whatever who cares you have to be
conscious oh it seems a little
coincidental to be
um sharing that at that time but sharing
his favorite clip Kev also know what
it's like to have a Litany of false
accusations this is all litany there's
like a whole Taurus girl rolled out
right
and they are all fake uh though
certainly the the Ponzi one was
retracted right
right overriding
um
this was actually somewhat
um encouraging Megan Kelly of former Fox
News she was a big deal in the right
wing circles just one of these really uh
nasty poisonous right wing or Talking
Heads uh she put out a really surprising
take about this and um
I'm sure she caught a lot of from
her
contemporaries too because you got to
kind of toe the line on these stuff the
knee-jerk Instinct Now by so many is
Russell Brand is wrongly accused these
women are all liars I'm sorry this is
extremely detailed and in the case of
The Other Woman There's an actual set of
medical records after she went to a Rape
Crisis Center the day of the alleged
encounter wow somebody read the articles
article she can read good are you
surprised to find out that all of your
conservative buddies in media are uh
that they can reacting this way Megan
yeah are you shocked maybe man that's
some thoughts girl come girl we're here
plus apologetic begging for forgiveness
text from Russell Brand could you please
for our second stay open-minded to the
possibility that the women mine did just
read the article man not asking you to
imagine uh capitalism ending right
clearly this is uh this is not ground a
known sex addict like lunatic actor uh
turned out to be a sex Pastor you don't
need your time not that ground chicken
no are telling the truth we don't need
to so over correct from the metoo
movement that every woman gets
completely disregarded and called a liar
when she finds the guts to come forward
and make an allegation they may be
telling the truth it's worth
investigating we don't need to Nature
condemn him and we don't need to
knee-jerk condemn them I'm just she
won't even say she's been sitting a
little bit better
offending him yeah she makes it all
about the
victim we don't need to attack her we
don't need the defender Russ she won't
even mention Russell
sit she's fencing but still impressed
because what I've seen is like a rash of
guys coming out to be like it's
you don't know whether it's or
not did you read the report of this
woman no did you read the rape the
alleged rape details did you read the
text message that she has
from Russell Brand begging for
forgiveness there's at least enough for
us to want more facts girl you are
fencing he did that but anyway
still impressive right I thought it was
pretty good at least she's trying yeah
she's trying
uh so that that was that was you know a
a Moment of clarity in the conservative
sphere I don't know you might say I
think a lot of conservatives don't like
her though because uh I think she's a
woman
yes
this is mine oh my God oh my God
it's so big oh yeah this is a lot oh my
God clip that
oh my God
shows over folks that's about it we
gotta go wait I got the mint underneath
let me try that are you sick still yeah
you're right I promise
I managed to stay out of it until now is
this a new headline
from about Trump having to pay 5 million
no that's old
oh that's her talk but that's a recent
interview with Trump so
funny so now that it's open
um lots of previous brand stuff is
resurfacing all interview with Vogue his
ex-wife Katy Perry
had interesting comments to say quote
let's just say I haven't heard from him
since he texted me saying he was
divorcing me and uh 2011.
at first when I met him he wanted an
equal he wanted an equal I think a lot
of times strong men do want an equal but
then they get that equal and they're
like I don't I can't handle this
equalness he didn't like the atmosphere
of being
of me being the boss on tour so that was
really hurtful and it was very
controlling which was upsetting but the
lot of responsibility for ending for an
ending but then I found out the real
truth which I can't necessarily disclose
because I keep it locked am I safe for a
rainy day
I let go and I was like this isn't
because of me this is beyond me so I
have moved on
okay open the safe I think yeah can we
have open that sooner I think the the
rainy day is here yeah I think it's
probably time we could have opened that
a little sooner well we don't actually
know what she meant by that
well what does she mean rainy day to
cover her to see if she needs you know
what I mean she has she has um
yeah I don't know yes collateral that's
what it means I don't know huh
um
now let's watch the new Russell video
okay at long glass I'm so excited to
watch this
obviously it's been
so man this ice cream is good this ice
cream is good yeah they put salt in it
yeah it's like salty caramel and cookie
dough got a damn
God damn all right stop hello there you
Awakening wonders obviously it's been an
extraordinary and distressing week and I
thank you very much for your support and
for questioning the information that
you've been presented with oh my God by
now you'll probably put your hands down
the British government have asked
they're a little software platforms to
censor our online content and the some
online platforms have complied with that
request I had to watch it twice well you
may not know yeah I don't know this
happens in the comments this is the
British government is suppressing people
defending him or him literally he's just
a repackaged Andrew Tate right now he's
just saying the Matrix basically like I
think is that that campaign team may
have gotten the major thing from that
can't be true right the information
I think someone asked Rumble some
government asked Rubble to get him off
or something
I guess I gotta look this up I don't
know what he's referring to here this
might be breaking news I feel that he
could have been more specific I thought
he was just talking about YouTube or he
could just be lying we posted it through
YouTube I'm supposed to do his YouTube
channel
actually let's watch it there so I can
read comments
um
uh yeah I just found that same article
can you send me the link yeah
oh to the YouTube link
rejects MP's called to demonetize she's
just demonetized some okay some an MP
which is like a senator I guess kind of
or representative uh
one individual one called for a private
company to demonetize them and they did
that's like that's the British yeah
exactly it's like Yale CNN let's not
dude you I can't believe you have Cuomo
on payroll you got to stop that yeah I
mean I guess to be fair it is like
you know it is a serious thing for like
an actual government official to
well I don't know anything about the
person I I don't know the intricacies
I don't know
so three hours ago 200 000 views people
are loving it
let's go to the comments
um
so our comments off that'd be kind of
epic
the citizens freedom of expression must
be safeguarded from the authorian UK
government by the way he just said
demonetized
right
you know
are they even monetized there
I don't even know that I don't think
they have ads
Russell we stand with you on Rumble yeah
I think so
who's running ads there except crypto
scams I guess yeah I mean my pillow yeah
there's a whole conservative ecosphere
you know with uh that's all we got like
gold yeah it's probably like uh yes
exactly
um so what do you call it the slot
buckets the uh survival kits or whatever
yeah slot bucket yeah all that kind of
stuff silver solution
um
that's awesome Russell we stand with you
we know why they're doing this stay
strong not only threat to the
establishment but also a threat to those
who would keep us divided he's a threat
to the sandwich for sure his 80 000 view
interview with Dave Rubin had everybody
shaking
I think most people stand with Russell
and see this for what it is George
Orwell hit the nail on the head in 1984.
damn yo he read 1984.
um
I don't know I don't I don't think
people understand what that means when
they say that
I wonder how because they love they love
1984. I wonder how many of them know
that George Orwell was a socialist I
wonder how many of them have read it
that too that too about as many as read
the article yeah I don't like reading
I thought hold on 1984 he wrote about
Russia yeah
yeah he was uh he was anti-stalling but
as many socialists were like we were
talking about yesterday I don't want to
get into it again please
anyway
Hallelujah you Awakening wonders
beautiful souls
in an extraordinary and distressing week
and I thank you very much for your
support and for questioning the
information that you've been presented
with
by now you're probably aware that the
British government have asked big Tech
platforms to censor our online content
and the sum online platforms have
complied with that
requests
on YouTube right now
did you want to monetize your video
about rape allegations I'm sorry
on YouTube right now sweeping
surveillance and
censorship powers and it's a law that
has already been passed
I also don't imagine you've heard of The
Trusted news initiative now as is often
the case when a word like trusted is
used as part of an acronym to describe
an unelected body trust is the last
thing you should be offering
The Trusted news initiative is a
collaboration between big Tech and
Legacy Media organizations to Target
control choke and shut down Independent
Media organizations
uh this seems like he's not a it seems
like it's not even about allegations I
guess simply be honest he's talking
about this this law that is uh being
debated in Parliament right now in the
UK oh yeah I mean obviously comments are
about the allegations
well I mean obviously that's what
everybody wants to actually hear about
because
kind of I mean there is there is
relation here because uh
but yeah he's like trying to kind of
conflate what's going on in the UK with
the YouTube ban but that that band had
nothing to do with that so high level
clickbait brother yeah Bill Gates did
what to the fruit
he's like yeah my weekend was kind of
mid but anyways about this YouTube yeah
yeah how would you guys wake him
were we talking about that on our show
on Monday on ramble but just to give you
an idea what the TNI is this is a quote
from one of their spokespeople Because
the actual real rivalry now is not
between the BBC and CNN globally it's
actually between all trusted news
providers and digital platforms it's
clear that these organizations
collaborate in constructing narratives I
mean it is about the allegation who's
trying to discredit the entire media
apparatus right except Rumble worldwide
except for they sent me one but Rumble
everyone's lying to you but me whoever
that's around the war or the pandemic
and of course there are other examples
and it's very clear to me we have to be
very very cautious indeed
that's why I'm asking you to follow me
on Rumble Rumble have made a clear
please support me on Rambo meant to free
speech and Rumble is the primary
platform that we will be streaming from
we'll be back this Monday
and as usual we'll be talking about deep
State and corporate collusion and how
ordinary democracy is anathema now how
it's shut down ignored and avoided we'll
be talking about a military-industrial
complex that is able to facilitate and
start wars that seem sometimes to be
little more than money laundering
operations and that's with all respect
to the hundreds of thousands of victims
of the numerous ongoing wars in the
world at the moment we'll be talking
about the role of big Pharma and how big
Pharma
this new clickbait is rape allegation
right huh
I'm just saying this dude he did he
clickbaited that
that's crazy it's pretty good it's
working and people don't even realize
yeah because it's it's just like what uh
okay I I support you
I support you bro
being able to influence government
policy around the world yeah and how
they've been able to evade I support you
liability and necessary scrutiny how
they've been able to avoid they're
coming first but perhaps or we do them
and of course we'll be talking about
media corruption and censorship
so please follow me on Rumble because
that's the only way that we can keep our
voice
you can go to ask you dot rumble.com
he's scared he's he might go to jail
I mean the evidence is enough to send
him there it seems like
I guess it's up to the
the DN
I don't know what's the law
or what happened but he looks scared bro
it looks pretty bad in this video
um
I didn't pay attention to a word he said
I was too distracted by him doing all
this
not not a single sentence there needed
all this
are you sure
hold me directly and keep me and our
Channel independent
and I need your support now more than
ever I'm more than I ever imagined I
would and you just worked please guys
and so please don't trust the media and
actually stay off the internet for the
next year
yeah don't look up anything about me
you'll see it if you see an article just
close it close the articles
they're all lying
close your eyes shut your ears
the truth the only truth is here at
rumble.com Russell Brand
all right we gone way over it
thank you everybody
for being here thank you for watching
have a great weekend Russell Brand won't
be
Batman
thank you to our wonderful mods
perfect oh my God we didn't get to do
the mod game
I'm sorry guys whatever
it's okay man you got a Life to Live
it's true I have a life to live I do
I wanted to get you guys out here though
next time yeah
anyway
um
thank you to Avery
okay
thank you to Ray
thank you too
Kev Kev not to be confused with Cav cab
he's cab and we love Kev Kev yeah we
call him the wolf
he's the good one
no he's not one they're different he's
Kevin
right and wait for the wolf
dude I just had the Fried Chicken ice
cream was it good no wow you didn't
sound good no it's really bad you try
the kamis
not the coming no
the fried chicken one though those
are actually Fried Chicken in it yeah I
think they kind of like mashed it up or
some they probably blended with
sugar or some maybe it's supposed
to be like a chicken and waffles type
thing
see I would have came about that one
because I have chicken waffles from
Baskin robbizo and it was it wasn't it
man
yeah I just don't think it belongs to
the ice cream you got chicken at Baskin
Robbins
yeah they had they had a chicken and
waffles flavor for a limited time I mean
my roommates
it was disgusting we got the music
playing
yet they keep selling it all right we
really gotta go
thank you everybody with all the peace
and love in the world thank you thank
you thank you thank you for watching a
great weekend we'll see you on Monday
[Music]
thank you